bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
deuxième leçon de paléo mammalogie ce
deuxième cours sur l'évolution des
mammifères avec ce petit point de vue
africain qui me permet de faire secours
à mes étudiants ici en afrique du sud
et aujourd'hui eh bien on va parler de
d'animaux qui sont très diverses sur le
continent africain puisqu'il s'agit des
arts sio dactyle et des périseaux
dactyle alors la dernière fois c'était
un petit peu pauvre en contenu africain
parce qu'on a parlé des mots notres m et
des marsupiaux qui ont une distribution
essentiellement pas africaine
mais voilà ce coup ci on va attaquer
vraiment les animaux les les groupes où
il ya vraiment de beaucoup d'exemples en
afrique mais il ya aussi beaucoup
d'exemples qu'on peut donner qui sont
européens bien sûr donc les a reçus au
tactile et l'épée risso dactyle ce sont
des grands herbivores
les groupes dominants d'herbivores
aujourd'hui représentée notamment par
les ruminants et les chevaux enfin les
chevaux les zèbres ne sont que des
chevaux en pyjama évidemment donc je
généralise évidemment quand je dis
chevaux je devrais dire équidés et puis
évidemment on parlera des rhinocéros et
des cétacés
mais d'abord comme secours s'intitule
les ongulés partie 1
eh bien il va falloir commencer par
définir ce qu'est un [ __ ] et être très
clair sur ce qu'on appelle à l'engueuler
parce qu'un onglet c'est pas n'importe
quoi alors autrefois les ongulés c'était
un clad le clad ont bu la tasse
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est plus considéré
comme un cloud mais on continue à
utiliser le mot pour une raison très
simple c'est que c'est un très très bon
adjectif c'est un mot qui décrit très
bien une certaine une certaine catégorie
d'animaux donc on utilise encore le mot
engueuler mais dans un but strictement
descriptif donc un animal et qu'on s'y
est considéré comme ongulés un animal
est décrit comme étant un onglet quand
il a des sabots et voilà engueuler
ongles sabots
c'est de là que ça vient donc un animal
est appelé à non gül et quand il a des
sabots cela correspond généralement à
des animaux herbivores les sabots étant
une adaptation à la course pour la
plupart des ongulés mais évidemment on
va avoir des exceptions
donc il s'agit d'un herbivore
généralement de grande taille quand je
dis de grande taille c'est pas par
opposition aux rongeurs que j'appelle
des herbivores de petite taille
donc on est sur des animaux de taille
moyenne à gross qui ont des sabots qui
sont généralement on gulli grade
donc encore une fois on retrouve la
racine ongles la même racine que dans
ongulés c'est à dire qu'il marche sur
les phalanges terminal donc les la
phalange ont dû al d'où leur nom dont
bull est et d'où cette démarche on bully
grade
donc on oppose cette démarche en buli
grade à la démarche plantigrade qui est
la nôtre celle de nos pieds où on marche
sur la totalité du pied et la démarche
digitick grade qui est typiquement celle
des chats ou des chiens donc celle où on
marche sur les doigts et non pas sur les
métatarse donc ici voulait métacarpe si
vous regardez les mains pour les
quadrupèdes
donc voilà plantigrade marche sur les
métatarse
digi tigran marche sur les phalanges
ongulés grade ne marche que sur la
finlande que sur la phalange en guyane
et ça c'est un des caractères c'est une
des caractéristiques des ongulés et
cette phalange en guyane et est
recouverte dassa beau donc de ce soit
alors soit d'un sabot soit évidemment
plusieurs sa bosse il y a plusieurs doit
évidemment et il y à d'autres petits
caractères qui sont importants chez les
ongulés généralement ils ont une barre
post orbitaire donc c'est à dire qu'ils
ont une orbite est fermé à l'arrière ce
qui solidifie le crâne est généralement
compris comme étant une adaptation à la
mastication quoi ça se solidifie le
crâne contre les contraintes à la
mastication
mais surtout quand on regarde les dents
parce que les mammifères et et c'est
tout à propos des dents voilà tout est
sur les dents quand on parle de
mammifères donc vous avez le plan
tribaux scénique de base des mammifères
et les ongulés vont systématiquement
voir une nouvelle structure à paraître
qui s'appelle l'ipo caunes donc l'ipo
caunes c'est le quatrième caunes qui va
transformer la surface mastic à trice
d'une surface triangulaire donc
primitivement triangulaire en une
surface rectangulaire ou carré donc
ça augmente la surface d'occlusion et
donc la capacité de mastication puisque
la nourriture la fibre végétale sont
beaucoup plus durs à mâcher que les
protéines enfin que toute forme de
fibres animales quoique toute forme de
protéine animale donc que ce soit des
insectivores ou des carnivores voilà
généralement on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
des d'avoir des dents à surface
occlusale rectangulaire mai et
primitivement les mammifères étaient
insectivores donc le type affective or
évolué vers un type herbivores en
développement justement cette hypothèse
alors l'ipo conne il peut évoluer à
partir d'un bout de saint guillaume donc
le saint guillaume c'est un petit repli
des mailles supplémentaires à l'arrière
de la dent où il peut évoluer à partir
du meta qu'au nul et c'est à partir de
ça qu'on va distinguer les deux lignes
et donc si vous avez un saint guillaume
formé à partir du meta connu lé sait que
vous regardez un art sio dactyle et si
vous avez un saint guillaume qui se
forme à partir de l'ipo caunes c'est que
vous regardez à perry sow dactyle alors
à noter que les primates aussi ont
évolué un iphone à partir d'un saint
guillaume donc à partir du moment où
vous évoluez un régis merville où vous
vous adaptez à un régime herbivores vous
avez vous avez développement d'un
hippocampe d'une façon ou d'une autre
donc déjà le développement de l'ipo code
n'est pas le même chez les a reçus au
tactile et les personnes actives et ça
c'est important de le noter
et les lézards cieux dactyle et les
périodes acte ils sont très importants
parce qu'ils permettent de caractériser
les changements paléo environnementaux à
travers tout le cénozoïque donc ils sont
tous originaires de groupes qui étaient
primitivement des brewers comme on le
dit en anglais donc des défauts lievore
des follivores aider frugivores donc il
était adaptée à un environnement
forestier et rappelez vous allez hossein
le monde entier est couvert de forêts il
n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de calottes polaires et à
l'oligocène et bien la calotte polaire
les calottes polaires se forment la
glaciation les glaciations commence et
c'est là qu'on va avoir une arme
édification du climat et on va voir
s'adapter les ans les herbivores à des
régimes beaucoup plus riche en graminées
donc vous voyez ici par exemple les
chevaux des lignes et qui vont s'adapter
qui vont rester adapté aux régimes
follivores des lignes et qui vont
devenir des mixes et feeder ce donc des
mix quoi d intermédiaire entre des
follivores et des grammy nivore et des
lignes et qui vont devenir totalement
grammy niveau or il se trouve que la
lignée des chevaux la famille des
équidés ne va terminer qu'avec un seul
genre le genre etc ou ce dont tout lé
tous les chevaux ânes et zèbres actuelle
appartiennent à un seul genre le jean
eklou donc c'est ce qui est une faible
une très très faible représentation de
ce qu'était la diversité des chevaux
comme vous pouvez le voir au miocène
mais ceci est une autre histoire pour
l'instant là l'idée c'est que voilà à
partir de l'oligocène on va globalement
voir les les herbivores s'adapter un
régime graminées bord et ça c'est très
important pour retracer justement
l'évolution des des savanes et des
steppes donc où est ce que
l'environnement est devenu couvert de
savane et de step il suffit de suivre
les les mammifères et et ça va être
important aussi pour reconstituer des
par les eaux des paléo environnement
locaux donc par exemple si vous trouvez
des primates et que vous voulez savoir
dans quel environnement vives primates
vous pouvez vous servir des herbivores
qui accompagnent ces primates donc on va
commencer par les cet art sio dactyle
donc une contraction du mot art sio
dactyle et du mot c'est assez puisque
les cétacés font partie de cette famille
comme l'ont montré les analyses
génétiques
donc voilà la phylogénie décès darciaux
dactyle à la base vous avez les
camélidés puis les swing et donc les
cochons puis les ruminants donc à savoir
que les camélidés ne font pas partie de
la famille des ruminants contrairement à
ce qu'on pensait autrefois les les
camélidés rumine aussi mais finalement
c'est une adaptation convergentes
la génétique a montré que
la rumination a évolué deux fois ensuite
vous avez les hippopotames idée donc les
hippopotames qui sont le groupe frère
des cétacés donc vous avez un groupe qui
fait à peu près sens dans son adaptation
au milieu aquatique et tout cela a
évolué au moins il y a à partir de 65
millions d'années
jeudi au moins parce qu'il ya des files
au génie qui place la racine des
scénarios dactyle encore plus loin dans
le temps mais voilà on pense que c'est
il ya au moins 65 millions d'années que
c'est ce groupe a évolué mais
rappelez-vous le premier set a reçus au
tactile est en fait un cétacé et il y
des vieux entre guillemets que de 53
millions d'années donc mais bon à 53
millions d'années on est déjà tout au
sommet de l'arbre donc ça montre que
quand même il ya de très fortes
probabilités que cette date soit sinon
vrai au moins proche de la vérité donc
est alors bon il ya débat sur la
terminologie est ce qu'on devrait parler
de cet art sio dactyle est ce qu'on
devrait parler darciaux dactyle pour
être tout à fait honnête je j'utilise
les deux mots de façon totalement
interchangeables maintenant on sait
aujourd'hui voilà il ya peut-être vingt
ans encore on aurait pu avoir ce débat
là mais aujourd'hui on sait que quand on
parle darciaux dactyle on parle en fait
de cet art you dactyle donc
donc maintenant je vais utiliser le mot
art cieux dactyle et cet art you dactyle
de façon interchangeable d'ailleurs je
l'utilisais déjà de façon
interchangeable
alors les a reçus au tactile ou c'est
tahar sioud dactyle comment est ce qu'on
les reconnaît quand on en trouve des
fossiles et bien c'est très simple on
regarde leur zoo et notamment les os du
pied et dans les os du pied les os de la
cheville
l'os de la cheville donc qu'on appelle
l'astragale chez les a reçus au tactile
à une double poulies donc voila voila
les deux poulies en rouge donc en fait
vous avez quand vous regardez le pied en
fait vous avez une poulie qui s'articule
avec le tibia ici donc ce qui est normal
mais vous avez aussi une poulie qui
s'articule avec les méta tard avec les
tarse et les méta tu as donc vous avez
un double mouvement de balancier chez
les a reçus au tactile ce qui peut
s'interpréter de diverses façons mais
globalement ça ça aide à courir plus
vite
donc voilà l'astragale
double police et le caractère signature
17 ar cieux dactyle c'est vraiment le
caractère qu'on retrouve chez tous les
arts se dactyle de façon complètement
conserver et on verra que même les
cétacés à la base avait un astragale une
astra gala double poulies l'autre
caractère signature des cétacés c'est le
membre par axones hic membres par
action' hic ça veut dire qu'il y a un
nombre pair de doigts et que l' axe de
symétrie passe entre les doigts du
milieu donc je m'explique
voici un cochon insère un chameau est en
fait vous avez soit 4 soit deux doigts
et toujours les doigts du milieu donc
les doigts 2 et 3 que ce soit sur la
main ou sur le pied sont les doigts qui
porte le poids de l'animal
donc même quand vous avez des doutes et
gros doigts latéraux comme chez un
cochon ou chez un hippopotame par
exemple vous avez quand même les doigts
du milieu qui sont les plus gros et l'
axe de symétrie passe entre ses deux
doigts
que vous ayez deux ou quatre doigts et
donc ça c'est le membre par axones hic
le deuxième caractère signature des
désertions dactyle donc c'est pour ça
que en anglais ils sont appelés les
event houde en bus lights est alors un
petit mot pour vous reparler de
l'astragale à double poulies un petit
mot cette astra gala double poulies elle
a une forme très particulière et du coup
elle a une énorme importance culturelle
donc là vous voyez deux exemples de
de ce que peuvent faire les
sud-africains justement de culture
totalement opposées en afrique du sud et
qui ont tous les deux indépendamment
remarqué la forme très particulière de
cette astra gala double poulies donc là
étant les afrikaners dont les ancêtres
qu'on appelle les bourgs utilisaient les
astragale à double poulies pour faire
des chevaux sur des jouets chariot en
fait donc ça c'est un jouet chariot le
le la mâchoire fait le chariot et les
astragale font les chevaux à l'avant où
les boeufs suivre ça dépend ça dépend
jusqu'à quel point vous avez une vision
romantique de la chose évidemment
donc ça a joué qui étaient utilisés
pendant le grand trek en afrique du sud
par les par les enfants des débours donc
les fermiers afrikaners de l'époque est
ici vous avez ce que les sud africains
appellent les amas tambo donc c'est un
peu le lait un assemblage dos et de
divers objets en fait que qu'utilisent
les sorciers pour la divination donc les
sorciers noire des peuples africains
natif devrais je dire
donc voyez ce indépendamment ses deux
sociétés totalement différente on
remarquer l'importance de ces eaux et il
n'y a pas que puisque nous mêmes nous
utilisions ou utilisions du mois les
astragale à double poulies pour faire un
jeu qui s'appelait les osselets donc
voilà les plus anciens d'entre vous s'en
rappellent encore avant qu'on ait les
smartphones avant qu'on ait les gameboy
et ben on se faisait chier et on jouait
avec des sourds et on jouait avec des
astragale à double poules y voilà
demandez à vos grands parents à vos
parents même si ça se trouve ils ont
connu les osselets peut-être pas les
vraies mais au moins cela en plastique
alors les ars you dactyle si on reprend
notre petit arbre phylogénétique qu'on a
vu la dernière fois
ou se place-t-il et bien il se place
parmi les lots razia teria lézard cieux
d'actes ils sont dès lors asia terrienne
ils appartiennent donc oklad cet art sio
d'acti là et selon les files aux jeunes
ils sont placés plus ou moins proche des
périseaux dactyle donc soit soit ils
sont placés groupe frère dépérissent au
tactile au sein d'un groupe qu'on
appelle les ions gül atau eux ont vu là
tu as 2 e vrai et angula tas pour
engueuler soit soit ils sont dans cette
disposition là et dans ce cas là le clad
n'a pas vraiment de nom est le plus
ancien a reçus au tactile dont on est
alors le plus ancien à cet art cieux
dactyle dont on ait des preuves dans le
rhône et des traces dans le registre
fossile comme je voulais 10 et himalaya
cetus mais himalayas et us c'est juste
une mâchoire donc c'est un peu dur de
voir les caractères typiques des
scénarios dactyle sur himalayas et us le
plus ancien dont on est une astra gala
double poulies et des membres par axones
x et dia codexis dire codexis c'est le
scénario dactyle basale par excellence
et on le trouve partout dans le monde en
tout cas dans l'hémisphère nord on mais
on le trouve aussi en inde qui fait
partie du continent gondwana mais à
l'époque l'inde avait déjà commencé à
rentrer en collision avec l'asie donc
bon à ce qu'on l'appelle hémisphère nord
ou pauvres c'est vous qui voyez
mais voilà dia codexis on le retrouve en
inde on le retrouve en europe on le
retrouve en amérique donc dire codexis
est partout à partir de la fin du
paléocène et au début de l'éocène et
donc c'est un art sio dactyle qui est
primitivement buno dompter bras qui
dompte donc ça veut dire que ses dents
sont à couronne basse et les coûts et
les
et les culs speed sont
sont relativement arrondi donc c'est un
animal qui était probablement un browser
donc à follivores et il a cette espèce
de courbure dans le dos qui est aussi
primitive chez les a reçus au tactile
qu'on retrouve encore un peu chez
certains traduit l'idée notamment
on en reparlera plus tard alors se dire
codexis il est quand même pas sorti de
nulle part il n'est pas apparu comme ça
avec son astra gala double poulies non
évidemment
l'un des groupes qui pourrait être le
groupe de mammifères non martiaux
dactyle le plus proche des arceaux
dactyle ça pourrait être les maisons
nick idée alors les maisonny kid et ça
vous parle peut-être pas mais si je vous
dis andrews arcus là tout de suite ça
devrait vous parlez en aux arcs us c'est
le monstre par excellence le
probablement un des plus gros carnivore
qui ait jamais existé et en fait il se
trouve que andrew arcus était un [ __ ]
il avait des sabots au bout des pattes
et il avait des membres par axones ya
alors on n'a pas de je crois pas qu'on
ait deux squelettes d'andrews arcus mais
aussi les proches parents lui même de
mai aux knicks qui a donné son nom à la
famille des maisons liquider l amazonie
que celui a définitivement vous voyez un
deux trois quatre doigts à chaque à
chaque membre et les deux doigts du
milieu sont plus gros et sont les
porteurs de charge donc un membre par
axones ya par excellence chez mes onyx
qu'avait aussi en dose arcus donc voilà
on a un membre par axones hien chez les
mets zonic idée mais nous n'avons pas
d'astra gala double poulies et donc ça
ça vous montre bien en face à ça nous
montre ça nous indique du moins que les
maisons liquider sont les mieux placés
on va dire pour être le groupe de
mammifères à l'origine des arts sio
dactyle les maisons liquide et
appartiennent même à un groupe qui
s'appelle les condyles artres dont on
reparlera très souvent c'est un groupe
qui est possiblement poliphile éthique
ou par affi l'éthique c'est à dire
qu'elle c'est un groupe qui a donné
naissance à tellement de groupes
différents en fait que c'est que c'est
fort probable qu'ils aient pas
d'ancêtres communs ont conduit la
retraite donc c'est probablement un
c'est ce qu'on appelle un waste basket
poubelles quoi en fait un taxon poubelle
on y met à peu près tout ce qui est on
du l'aimé pas mais on y met tout ce qui
a des sabots mais qui n'était ni un
arceau d'actes il n'y a péri sous
dactyle ni un péno gueulé mais les
pennons gül et on verra ça la semaine
prochaine donc pour l'instant on se
concentre sur les ars united les persos
dactyle voilà donc sabots par actio
niamey pas de double poulies donc
probablement probablement un groupe
voilà qu'il manquait cette petite scie
napo morphy pour deux pour faire partie
des arceaux dactyle et on note aussi que
les maisons ni qia commandes rose arcus
par exemple était carnivore
donc ça c'est donc c'est c'est
finalement c'est ce qu'on a de plus
proche d'une chèvre carnivores
finalement les maisons ni 15 c'est du
bouc mangeurs de chair quoi un bouc
mangeur d'hommes donc voilà à peu près à
quoi ressemblerait l'arbre
phylogénétique des arceaux dactyle donc
vous voyez les arceaux dactyle ici avec
leur astragale à double poulies ici une
astragale classique avec son petit voilà
sa petite construction l'astragale
typique des teria avec une articulation
pour le tibia mais pas d'articuler enfin
pas de
de poulies pour le lait et ars et donc
les maisonny qu'un se brancherait ici
avec des maisonny qu'un comme cris
accuse ce qui serait encore plus près
des des arceaux dactyle que d autres
mais honni tiens donc on est voilà voilà
à quoi on s'attend au niveau
phylogénétique alors voilà on a fini
avec l'origine des arceaux dactyle on
allait on laisse tomber dia codexis on
laisse tomber tout ça on va s'atteler à
décrire maintenant les groupes modernes
darciaux dactyle ce qu'on rencontre
aujourd'hui et on va avoir de toutes
façons ils ont tous une origine très
lointaine dans le semnoz oic donc il est
fort probable que la plupart des arceaux
dactyle qu'on trouve dans le registre
fossile s'attache plus ou moins aux
groupes modernes donc le plus banal des
groupes darciaux dactyle encore que ce
soit discutée puisque là je vous ai
montré que défilent au génie qui place
les ti l'opod à la base il ya certaines
phylogénie qui place les cochons à la
base mais bon on va suivre les fils au
génie qui place les ti l'opod à la base
en sachant en gardant dans un coin de
l'esprit que possiblement il ya de la
controverse derrière ça alors les ti
l'opod bas ce sont les chameaux et
dromadaires donc les dromadaires ils ont
une bosse les chats monde de bosses 1
vous connaissez tous l'histoire est
alors les ti l'opod il se distingue par
plusieurs caractéristiques mais la plus
importante c'est quand on regarde leurs
pieds ils ont ce qu'on appelle la noce
canon c'est à dire qu'ils ont une fusion
des métatarse ou des métacarpe si vous
regardez les
les mains donc cette hausse canon vous
le voyez ici mais celle est-il au pod
l'os cannes on n'est pas complet il
n'est pas fusionner en bas ce qui donne
la fameuse morphologie en camel tout
voilà où kamel toe qui fait le buzz
régulièrement sur internet voilà c'est
de là que ça vient ça vient de là non
fusion finalement de c2c métatarse et de
ses métacarpe au moins deux au moins sur
la terminaison distale voilà donc fusion
proximale et non fusion distale ça c'est
vraiment le truc des ti l'opod après
vous avez d'autres caractères donc les
dents des ti l'opod sont ipso celeno
d'onde c'est à dire en forme de
croissant de lune et à croissance
continue ce qui est totalement
convergent avec les ruminants les
ruminants aussi ont des dents ipsos et
les lots dont tu es s'est pincé
certainement pas un hasard puisque
l'éthylomètre
comme je voulais 10 sont aussi des
ruminants c'est à dire que leur estomac
à plusieurs poches et il régurgite mach
ingurgite régurgite machin gurgy tu donc
c'est là c'est ça la rumination alors
comment on va les distinguer des
ruminants si on n'a que la dentition et
bien il faut regarder la dentition
antérieur parce que si vous avez que les
molaires vous allez avoir du mal mais si
vous regardez la dentition antérieur et
bien vous allez y trouvait déjà des
canines des canines
au moins chez les mâles ce qui est
plutôt rare chez les ruminants on va
voir que ça arrive à chez les ruminants
mais c'est plutôt rare mais surtout vous
allez trouver des incisives
parce que ça c'est la canine mais ça
c'est les incisives de votre
votre chapeau donc les incisives sont
gigantesques et canini forme chez les ch
et les ti l'opod alors que chez les
ruminants il n'ya pas d'un sixième du
tout les ruminants complètement remplacé
les incisives par un espèce de morceaux
de kératine en fait qui va s'user contre
les incisives inférieur donc ça c'est
vraiment la manière la plus facile de
reconnaître les ti l'opod ils ont et
puis de manière générale ils ont un
crâne assez monstrueux les pilotes vous
pouvez voir ça m'est déjà arrivé que des
gens voient un crâne de chameau en me
disant oh mais il est beau votre crâne
de t-rex non c'est pas un crâne de t-rex
c'est pire que ça voilà et aussi on va
distinguer les ti l'opod des ruminants
par le fait que les ti l'open n'ont
jamais de corne
alors que les ruminants la plupart du
temps on des choses sur la tête c'est
pas forcément des cornes ça peut être
des bosses ça peut être des bois de
cerfs par exemple généralement les
ruminants ont un truc sur la tête
pas toujours mais généralement alors que
les ti l'open n'en n'ont jamais et vous
avez cette crête sagittale du cou qui
est très très bien très marqué alors que
chez les ruminants vous ne verrez pas ou
pas souvent de crédit sagittale alors ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant avec les chameaux
c'est qu'ils ont en fait une origine
américaine
donc là vous êtes en train probablement
de faire la connexion avec les lamas les
guanacos et tout ça bah oui les lamas
les guanacos les alpes paca ils vivent
en amérique du sud qui est finalement
beaucoup le plus proche de ce que vous
pouvez être du terrain d'origine des ti
l'opod mail et il oppose les tout
premiers t-il aux potes viennent en fait
d'amérique du nord
et ils sont ils se sont complètement
éteint d'amérique du nord à la fin de la
du dernier âge glaciaire donc entre
20000 et et dix mille ans de cela
donc ça c'est un des tout premiers t-il
au pod qu'on retrouve qu'on rencontre
dans le registre fossile pour hébreu
terium qui a vécu à la fin de l'est de
l'éocène et dans le lit gaussen en
amérique du nord et vous pouvez voir que
il a globalement quasiment tous dainty
l'opod à part qu'il est beaucoup plus
petit et que vous voyez la dentition
antérieur n'est pas encore aussi
différencier
dire le diastème entre les molaires et
les temps antérieurs et moins grands par
exemple les cochons alors les cochons
ils sont très faciles à reconnaître les
cochons ils ont d énormes canine déjà
qui leur servent de défense donc petites
précisions sur ce que j'appelle une
défense ce qu'on appelle une défense
c'est une dent qui n'a pas d'émail
voilà donc c'est une dent qui est fait
purement de dentine ou d'ivoire donc
c'est précisément dans le cas des
défenses que le mot ivoire remplace le
mot danthine mais c'est exactement la
même chose c'est de la dentine donc les
défenses ce sont des canines et du
coucher les suidés vous avez des normes
défense formé par les canines et vous
avez certaines formes fossiles qui ont
d'énormes canine mais qui sont pas
encore tout à fait des défenses
puisqu'elles ont encore de l'émail
mais voilà vous avez l'idée quoi donc
les défenses sont des canines pardon les
canines sont des défenses et les dans
son bras qui bruno dhont donc
typiquement un couronne basse et à la
cus pitbull buzz et chez les cochons en
particulier vous avez plein plein plein
de petit cul speed bulbeuses qui se sont
rajoutés en plus des 4 q speed principal
donc protoppas ram et à hypo voilà ça
c'est même une dent inférieur donc en
réalité c'est proto part à ces proto
meta antho hypo et hippo connu lead
voilà on va y arriver
mais voilà c'est l'idée en gros c'est
l'idée les pleins de petits extras qu
speed un peu partout des culs speed
supplémentaires et certains m'ont poussé
le délire de la cus pitt supplémentaire
très très loin comme le warthog c'est à
dire les phacochères donc sur la toute
dernière molaires donc juste sur celle
là
le nombre de cul speed augmente-t-elle
manche et le phacochère qu'en fait la
dernière muller est devenue gigantesque
et surtout elle est devenue ipso dont tu
donc on est sur un mode
buno ipso dont en fait oui pso bruno
dhont l'écu speed sont toujours les
mêmes
ce sont toujours des culs speed bruno
dhont mais comme la dent est en
croissance continue vous avez cette
usure très particulière qui donne à la
molaire la troisième molaire des
phacochères 7 se profile si particulier
donc ça c'est vraiment unique au
phacochères et les suidés on les
rencontre dans le registre fossile
jusqu'à très très loin dans le passé le
problème c'est qu'ils ont globalement
jusqu'à l'éocène le problème c'est
qu'ils ont une morphologie primitive un
bras qui bruno dhont c'est quand même
globalement plutôt primitif donc c'est
pas vraiment très claire quelles espèces
sont réellement décider et quelles
espèces sont rattachés au sud et juste
parce qu'elle ressemble primitivement à
des cochons en tout cas une chose est
sûre c'est que les antennes aux dons
entre eux font bien partie de la famille
des suis né enfin delà du de l'ordre dé
suis né donc un peu plus grands un peu
plus large que les suidés se sont pas
des vrais suidés mais ils appartiennent
au swing et et les intellos de bas c'est
un peu vous vous reconnaissez un peu le
profil dans d'ozark us chez les intellos
d'anti des c'est à peu près la même
histoire des grosses dents
bras qui bruno dhont est un peu c'est
co2 pour les prémolaires parce que
c'était un carnivore probablement
probablement un peu comme les hyènes
actuelle un broyeur dos vous voyez cette
énorme insertion du muscle masticatoire
ici cet énorme crête ici ou bien encore
là chez les intellos dont ty et qui sert
d'insertion aux muscles master et que
qui s'insérait sur la mâchoire
inférieure ici sur ces boss donc des
boss qui avait probablement des rôles
sexuels mais aussi d'insertion
musculaire parce que les muscles étaient
extrêmement puissant pour broyer les os
donc voila et encore une fois on ne s'y
trompe pas ça a beau être un carnivore
il n'a pas de griffe à regarder c'est
bien des sabots et c'est bien un membre
par actio nick par actio n'ya que qu'on
trouve chez les intellos dont il est
donc voilà les l'école et quand les
cochons bouffer un max de viande quoi
c'est de la balle donc les antonio
d'authie des on les trouve à partir de
l'éocène et ils ont ils ont ils ont
terreau terrorisé leur monde en asie
notamment et aussi en europe pendant le
lit gaussen donc on continue de monter
dans la phylogénie et maintenant on va
rencontrer enfin les ruminants donc
certainement l'un des groupes les plus
diversifiés de darciaux dactyle avec
quelques 300 espèces si ma mémoire ne me
fait pas défaut
300 espèces qui partagent néanmoins des
caractères donc une morphologie assez
conservez donc la première je vous le
disais tout à l'heure c'est la perte des
incisives supérieures donc vous avez des
incisives inférieur mais les incisives
supérieures ont été perdus et sont
remplacés par de la kératine qui
viennent lui qui viennent couper la
végétation sur les incisives inférieur
aussi vous avez une paire deux paires
d'incisives donc une paire et 2 perdent
incisive mais là de ce que vous croyez
être là la troisième à 6 yves est en
fait une canine transformé donc c'est
une canine assises yves assises y
forment donc ça c'est une canine
transformer c'est pas en fait c'est pas
une vraie incisive donc ça aussi c'est
un caractère typique des ruminants les
ruminants je vous le disais ont des
dents ipsos et leino d'hondt ou pour les
formes pour les formes
frugivores et follivores un poil plus
brackin bras qui sait les 90 mais la
couronne est globalement relativement
haute comparé par exemple à un cochon
donc
donc ça c'est déjà c'est important et ça
va de pair évidemment avec la rumination
donc comme celle et îlots potes vous
avez le rumen qui est fort mais enfin
vous avez quatre poches au niveau de
l'estomac donc la digestion se la
fermentation se fait au niveau du rumen
et non pas au niveau de la testa comme
c'est le cas chez les chevaux par
exemple ou chez les rhinocéros donc on
parle d'une donc c'est ça qui
caractérise la rumination la
fermentation n'a pas lieu dans
l'intestin dans le caecum ou du moins
pas que dans le sait comme elle a lieu
principalement dans ce qui est un
estomac très transformer et vous avez
des allers-retours constants entre la
bouche et l'estomac pour mâcher en fait
le bol alimentaire
donc voilà le voilà un ruminant typique
à une vache
et généralement ce que vous allez avoir
donc évidemment j'ai pris une femelle
qui n'a pas de cornes mais généralement
comme je voulais dit il y aura des
cordes des bois ou bien des hausses
icônes sur le crâne des ruminants que ce
qu'on ne trouve pas chez les autres a
reçus au tactile et au niveau des alors
au niveau des mains et des pieds
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant chez les a
reçus au tactile c'est qu'il ya aussi un
os canon mais cette fois c'est toscane
ont en fait et fusionnée distelmans
contrairement aux ti l'opod donc le tilt
aux potes vous avez ce petit intervalle
entre les métatarse qui n'existe pas
chez les ruminants ou chez les autres
arts cieux dactyle comme ce cétacé par
exemple donc ça c'est ainsi un caractère
des pieds qui est très important et un
autre caractère qu'on trouve chez les
ruminants
c'est le losc hugo naviculaire c'est à
dire que vous avez le snav hicules aires
et los cuboid qui sont fusionnés
ensemble et qui forment cette hausse en
z en fait qui s'articule à la fois avec
l'astragale et avec le calcanéum alors
que par exemple chez ati l'opod vous
avez voilà les deux os sont séparés ici
vous avez une belle futures entre les
deux et y en a un qui s'articule avec le
calcanéum et l'autre qui s'articule avec
l'astragale donc voilà pardon le premier
c'est là le deuxième est là par là je
montrais l'astragale en fait donc
voilà le losc hugo naviculaire résultat
de la fusion entre le qubo idem
naviculaire c'est une autre si napo
murphy à notre caractère typique des
ruminants et on le retrouve pour la
première fois en fait dans les
hauts-seine supérieur d'europe chez une
espèce qui s'appelle sedan fille
merricks chez qui vous pouvez
reconnaître d'ailleurs la magnifique
celeno dont six des ruminants une céline
ont d'aussi qui énorme néanmoins
accompagné de bras qui dont si donc la
couronne et basse mais les laitues
speedsource et les 90
donc c'est très très beau à une très
belle forme transitionnelle comme dirait
l'autre
alors les ruminants les plus bazot les
moins différenciés devrais je dire ce
sont les tracks eu l'idée alors chez les
tribus l'idée vous retrouver plein de
caractéristiques qu'on retrouvait déjà
chez dia codexis donc les dents déjà
sont plutôt à couronne basse du moins
comparé au hasard si au tactile plus
dérivés donc les danses sont à couronne
basse le régime et primitivement
follivores et frugivores d'ailleurs les
trades eu l'idée sont plutôt connus pour
être des frugivores et vous avez cette
courbure du dos comme chez dia codexis
donc un des caractères qui le
différencie plus de dia codexis qui
différencie les trades eu l'idée de dire
codexis c'est l'absence de que dire
codexis avait une très longue que donc
la silhouette générale était était un
peu différente quand même et ce qui est
ce qui est intéressant chez les
traboules idc les canines les canines à
dents de sabre chez les mâles donc les
mâles n'ont pas de cornes donc les
tribus l'idée non jamais jamais de
cornes donc on va voir que chez les
ruminants en fait le meilleur moyen de
distinguer les différentes familles
c'est de regarder ce qu'ils ont sur la
tête
donc voilà
s'ils n'ont rien sur la tête c'est
d'être à gulli des cylons des bois ce
sont des cervidés s'ils ont des os
icônes ce sont des girafes idées et
s'ils ont de vraies cornes
ce sont des bovidés voilà vous avez une
division des ruminants qui est très bien
définis par le
on va dire le merdier qu'ils ont sur la
tête et bien les traduit l'idée font
partie de ceux qui n'ont rien voilà ils
n'ont rien sur la tête mais par contre
du coup pour compenser ils ont des
petites dents de sabre et on va et on va
constater d'ailleurs un peu plus loin
que en fait c'est pas anodin ce ses
dents de sabre c'est pas c'est pas pour
rien qu'ils ont la combinaison dents de
sabre et rien sur la tête et donc les
tracks eu l'idée on les rencontre à la
fois en asie et en afrique dans les
jungles donc ce sont des animaux
forestier electra glide et se distingue
de tous les autres ruminants de tous les
ruminants plus dérivés par la forme de
leurs astragale donc vous reconnaissez
bien la double poulies est en fait celle
et réguler idée les deux poulies ne sont
pas alignés donc si vous tracez une
droite voilà ici et une droite qui passe
par la deuxième poule i ici en fait ces
deux droites ne sont pas parallèles
alors que chez les ruminants plus
dérivés les deux droites sont parallèles
et l'astragale à une forme globalement
rectangulaire donc cette forme
rectangulaire défini ce qu'on appelle
les pecora donc tous les ruminants plus
dérivés font partie de la famille des
pecora et cela inclut les cervidés donc
le premier groupe de pecora que nous
allons voir ce sont les cervidés les
cervidés qui se distinguent par leur
bois alors leur bois ne sont pas en bois
ils ne sont pas non plus en kératine il
s'agit bel et bien dos donc c'est un os
qui grandit chaque année généralement
chez les mâles bien que
bien que le caribou la femelle aussi à
des bois qui a des bois chez le caribou
mais le mal a évidemment des bois
beaucoup plus grands beaucoup plus
développé que les femelles mais le voilà
c'est un caractère sexuel
on va pas se tromper là dessus c'est un
caractères sexuels secondaires les bois
et donc chaque année le grand disent
donc ils sont recouvert d'une membrane
de pau qui permet des aubois de grandir
de nourrir le bol et bois et à la fin de
la saison reproductrices il ya une
petite zone de d'apoptose qui se forme à
la base du bois donc les cellules
s'autodétruisent et pouf les bois tombe
et c'est généralement là qui vont aller
se gratter sur les arbres pour faire
tomber la peau parce que ça doit faire
horriblement mal
non j'en sais rien j'en sais rien du
tout si ça fait mal ou pas j'imagine que
ça doit faire mal parce que moi elle
doit bien être énervé cette peau ça doit
gratter disons non pour employer des
pour employer des féminismes donc les
dents sont évidemment celeno d'hondt et
la couronne peut-être plus ou moins
autant fonction de si on est une et si
on regarde une espèce qui est follivores
ou grammy nivore donc là là où chez les
traduit l'idée on avait des espèces
uniquement follivores ou frugivores donc
purement buno don pur membres à qui donc
là on va avoir des formes qui peuvent
être certaines espèces vont être
une bras qui dot d'hondt et d'autres
vont être celeno dont tu donc et là où
je parlais tout à l'heure des canines et
bien c'est que on a une tendance
évolutif chez les cervidés en fait et
qui est très intéressante c'est que en
fait les cervidés les plus basses eaux
n'ont pas de bois ou des déboires
relativement petit et ont des très
grandes canines c'est par exemple le cas
des mots shide et les cervidés les plus
dérivés donc ceux qui sont le plus haut
dans l'arbre évolutive des cervidés ont
de très grands bois et de et non pas de
canines en fait et vous avez entre 2 le
bon c'est le sert par exemple où le
caribou et vous avez entre les deux le
des espèces comme le mundial qui ont une
combinaison de petit bois et de petites
canine et donc vous avez en fait un
genre de trade off un genre de
compensation en fait entre la taille des
canines et la taille des bois c'est à
dire que les bois en fait vont remplacer
les canines comme rôle de caractères
sexuels secondaires ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait le combat est le combat que
se livrent les cervidés bazzo et les
traduit l'idée entre mâles en fait avec
les canines et qui est un combat
extrêmement dangereux les morceaux s'ils
font ça en fait se finit par être
remplacé par un combat plus ritualisé où
ce sont les les bois qui se
qui vont servir de à se battre donc les
bois les uns contre les autres c'est
déjà vachement moins dangereux que les
canines plantées dans le corps du voisin
quoi et donc ça c'est a priori c'est une
tendance évolutive aussi qu'on retrouve
chez les rhinocéros
on va voir que chez les rhinocéros on va
passer de d'espèces qui ont des grosses
défenses à des espèces plus dérivés qui
ont des grosses cornes
voilà et qui perdent leur défense en
fait donc donc il ya une tendance
évolutive assez intéressante et qu'on
retrouve de multiples fois dans
l'évolution des mammifères mais aussi
des synapses id on en parlera quand on
fera l'évolution des synapses ide et
lada et enfin la famille des bovidés
alors la famille des bovidés qui est
certainement la plus diversifiée 2 tous
les ruminants donc la moitié des espèces
de ruminants presque sont des bovidés
donc c'est quand même pas rien et
évidemment en afrique vous avez une
diversité de bovidés absolument
formidable vous avez évidemment le bus
le buffalo vous avez les bikers
enfin vous avez le jedi coeur vous avez
je crois que ça c'est indique dit bon
évidemment à l'intérieur des bovidés
vous avez vous avez différentes familles
vous avez les bo va donc comme le
buffalo mais vous avez aussi les caprins
comme les chèvres et vous avez les
antilopes comme comme ici les élans ou
bien ça ça doit être un waterblock je ne
connais pas le nom en français des water
boc
ça c'est une artiste je sais même pas en
fait ils ont des noms français toutes
ces bêtes là qui est pire ça c'est un
james boxe ça c'est un ville de beast
donc c'est un gnou ça au moins c'est un
nom français le gnou donc bon reconnaît
alors c'est pas évident de faire la
différence entre les caprins les bovins
etc
pour une simple raison c'est que si vous
regardez s'il ya certaines espèces de
caprins en fait qu'ils sont des caprins
mais qui ressemble à des boeufs donc
c'est pas évident du tout en fait de le
différencier des caprins et des bovins
donc généralement généralement les
bovins ont les cornes lisse et les
caprins ont généralement les corps
d'anne les cornes
anne l'aimé pour face comme vous pouvez
voir il ya des antilopes
il ya des antilopes qui ont les cornes
années donc ça c'est pas c'est pas gravé
dans le marbre évidemment un mais voilà
et globalement vous avez le muscle qui
est très large chez les bovins alors
qu'il est plus fâché les caprins mais
les antilopes ont aussi le muscle fin
donc vous avez par exemple le boeuf
musqué là que je vous affiche à l'écran
donc le boeuf musqué vous pouvez voir ça
ressemble à un boeuf ça à toul allure du
boeuf ça a même le nom d'un boeuf est en
fait basse et un caprin donc voilà c'est
vous avez des petits pièges comme ça
alors les bovins les bovidés le meilleur
moyen de les reconnaître c'est encore
d'utiliser leurs cornes puisque les
bovidés sont les seules ars you dactyle
à posséder des cornes des vraies cornes
quand qui sont très spécial puisque il
s'agit de kératine mais de kératine qui
recouvre aussi une corne osseuse donc
vous avez à la fois une conque vous avez
une combinaison à la fois d'une corne
osseuse est recouverte d'une corne de
kératine et cette corne ce zettel même
creuse donc il ya le sinus parra nasale
donc un diverticules des sinus normaux
en fait qui s'étend à l'arrière jusqu'à
l'intérieur de la base des cornes donc
vous avez une combinaison creux os
kératine qui est complètement unique au
bovidés et qu'on retrouve dès le milieu
scène d
le début du miocène en namibie schena
macé rue ce qui est donc le plus ancien
bovidés connu qui avait déjà sept
petites cornes avec justement insinue
salles intérieures et des traces sur la
surface de l'eau ce qui montre qu'elle
était recouverte de kératine donc voila
et surtout chez les bovidés vous avez
systématiquement donc de fait vous avez
le plus ancien bovidés et qui a déjà des
cordes et du coup il y avait déjà ya
jamais de canines chez les bovidés
donc voilà la tendance est achevée
complètement chez les bovidés chez qui
on ne trouve jamais de canine est
systématiquement des ornementations
crânienne est évidemment chez les
bovidés vous allez avoir différentes
hauteurs de couronnes en fonction de si
vous êtes face à follivores comme ces
petits animaux ici ou même le coup
double coup du aussi est un follivores
ou bien si vous si vous êtes face à un
bon gros grammy nivore comme le buffle
voilà donc un exemple de bovidés qui
vaut le coup d'être mentionné c'est
pedro vi parce que deux ici à là vous
avez trois mètres d'envergure de corne
ce qui n'est pas rien donc c'est
probablement un des plus grands enfin
des bovidés avec les plus grandes cornes
qu'on ait pu retrouver dans le registre
fossile et il se trouve qu'en fait tu
paies lauro vi a beau ressembler
beaucoup à un buffle en fait il est de
la famille du gnou donc c'est un exemple
intéressant de convergence évolutive
donc là vous le voyez représentait quand
même comme un buffle
alors qu'en fait ils devaient plus
ressembler à un genou donc il devait
plus avoir cette tête là bon tenter que
si enfin si vous êtes tatillon au point
d'identifier les gnous à vue d'oeil
comme ça évidemment donc
donc voilà on a fait le tour un peu des
familles finalement de ruminants on n'a
pas encore vu les girafes mai
on peut voir les girafes rapidement dès
maintenant les girafes
si vous voulez c'est très simple les
girafes ce sont les seuls qui n'ont ni
cornes ni alors ni cornes ni bois ni
rien en fait ils ont un troisième truc
encore différent qui s'appelle des aussi
conne
voilà donc les petites les petites
antennes je sais que fera commandes
comment on pourrait appeler ça autrement
voilà ces petites antennes laquelle on
les girafes et qu'ils sont recouverts de
plus ou moins 2,2 d'un pinceau de poils
se sont ça s'appelle en fait des hausses
icônes et c'est aussi conne ils sont
formés 100 % en hausse et chez les mâles
vous avez même un aussi conne
supplémentaires qui se trouve sur le nez
et c'est aussi conne on ne rencontre pas
que chez les girafes on les rencontre
aussi chez les okapis donc même s'ils
sont très différents même si ils n'ont
pas du tout la même
voilà le même pyjama même s'ils n'ont
pas du tout le même profil de manière
générale même s'ils n'ont pas du tout le
même mode de vie les girafes vivant
savane les okapis vivent en forêt eh
bien ils ont cette particularité d'avoir
des aussi conne et là vous me voyez moi
en train de caresser and okapi donc
c'est plutôt cool j'ai eu l'occasion de
caresser à nos papilles et c'était quand
même c'était quand même la classe et
autres caractère qu'on les girafes donc
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
justement des incisives qu'on voyait
donc 1-2-3 incisive et une canine
incisif ormes et bâcher les girafes en
fait la canine 1 6i forme à cette petite
extension vers l'arrière
donc un deuxième globe et c'est pour ça
qu'on dit que la canine est biloba chez
les girafes idée donc on retrouve ça
aussi je trouve ça chez la girafe et
chez les okapis donc les girafes
elles ont un grand registre fossile très
très belle diversité au milieu scène
avec des hausses icône vous pouvez voir
qu'il était loin d'être aussi aussi
ennuyeux que ceux d'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez voir cela par exemple se sont pas
des bois ce sont bien des aussi conne
donc c'est de l'os pur massif il n'y a
pas de creux à l'intérieur et la surface
est différente la surface n'est pas
couverte de kératine elle est recouverte
de peau vous avez évidemment lessive à
terre donc les fameuses siva terium qui
sont les plus les girafes idées les plus
massifs qu'on ait pu rencontrer des
girafes idea coût relativement court et
a aussi conne et extrêmement développé
et vous avez les vous avez évidemment la
lignée des girafes sur laquelle on
retrouve ce hameau terium et beau ligne
à qui montrent en fait une tendance à
l'accroissement du de la longueur des
vertèbres qui culmine chez la girafe
alors quelque chose qu'on quelque chose
que j'ai pas mentionné au cours
précédent parce qu'en fait c'est un
caractère qu'on trouve déjà chez les ch
et les signaux dont tu mets tous les
mammifères ont strictement sept
vertèbres cervicales
jamais plus jamais moi il ya deux
exceptions ce sont les paresseux et les
sirénia qui peuvent avoir qui peuvent
avoir si vertèbres mais sinon le nombre
de vertèbres cervicales est solidement
fixée chez les chez les mammifères
c'est toujours ça sept vertèbres que
vous ayez le coup d'une girafe ou que
vous n'ayez pas de coups comme un cétacé
par exemple si vous regardez le coup
d'une baleine
il ya sept vertèbres cervicales qui sont
complètement compris mais les unes sur
les autres
mais vous pouvez en comptait 7 et léché
les girafes c'est pareil 1 2 3 4 5 6 et
donc les vertèbres sont très allongée
chez la girafe et on peut voir cette
tendance à l'allongement des vertèbres
dans la lignée ici qui mène aux girafes
moderne
donc on en revient à cette petite image
donc on avait les traits du l'idée
qu'ils n'avaient pas de qui n'ont aucun
ornement sur la tête on a les cervidés
qui ont les bois on a les bovidés qui
ont les cornes donc de l'os avec de la
kératine par dessus on a les girafes qui
ont que de l'os avec juste de la peau
par dessus et vous avez un dernier
groupe
un tout dernier groupe qui s'appelle les
antilles look a pris des et alors les
antilles au cap read et c'est
fantastique parce que ils cumulent tous
je m'explique
donc il s'agit d'un manchon osseux
nassif donc pas un manchot ce vide comme
chez comme chez les ruminants un manchon
au ce massif recouvert de kératine comme
chez les ruminants mais la kératine
tombe à chaque fin de saison
reproductrices comme les bois de cerf
donc voilà il culmine tout manchon ce
massif qui comme anne aussi conne
recouvert de kératine comme un bovidé
mais qui tombe le mée kératine qui tombe
à chaque saison
comme sur du bois de cerf voilà kamoulox
les antilles look à brider les antilles
look à brider c'est juste formidable
ils sont ils sont merveilleux c'est
dommage qu'ils n'en reste plus que
c'est dommage qu'ils ne reste plus que
les pronghorns qui sont les antilles
look a pris d'essai anti le genre anti
l'eau capra qui est le dernier survivant
et qui vit en amérique du nord est
strictement en amérique du nord
donc c'est dommage qu'ils restent plus
que mais voilà c'est juste magique
on a enfin avant les phylogénie
moléculaire on avait absolument aucune
idée de comment ça ça commençait
s'articuler où venait se mettre les
antilles au cap read et parmi les
ruminants alors que les bovidés c'est
comme je voulais enfin les bovidés les
ruminants même de manière générale c'est
la success story des arts sio dactyle
sur le milieu continental
on a aussi une success story en milieu
aquatique avec les cétacés mais c'est la
success story en milieux continental et
pourquoi
et bien parce que évolution de l'aridité
au cours du miocène donc à l'oligocène
vous avez le continent antarctique qui
va se séparer de l'amérique du sud est
va commencer à circuler le courant
circule en arctique qui va agir comme un
climatiseur en fait du monde et ce
climatiseur du monde il va provoquer une
crise d'aridité en fait parce qu'il va
concentrer finalement le lot sur le
continent antarctique dans les calottes
polaires et toute l'humidité toute
l'humidité de l'air va finir par
s'accumuler en antarctique au cours de
l'oligocène et ça va être le début
finalement de ce qu'on appelle les
grassland donc les savanes et les
steppes et le meut le mode de digestion
ruminants étant extrêmement efficace
beaucoup plus efficace que le mode de
digestion des périseaux dactyle donc le
mode de digestion ou c'est les intestins
qui servent de chambre de fermentation
si vous voulez eh ben les arceaux
dactyle comme vous pouvez le voir vont
finir par proliférer et prendre le pas
sur les persos dactyle tout au cours du
miocène et finalement à la fin de
de l'holocène quoi les architectes ils
vont être très largement dominant sur
les périodes active donc les persos
dactyle on va voir c'est une longue et
belle histoire mais qui finit mal
en fait les personnes actives à la fin
vous n'avez plus vous n'avez plus que un
seul genre de décider qui est le genre
le genre et cus et vous n'avez plus que
une seule famille de rhinocéros qui sont
les rhinocéros érode les rhinos érotisée
alors qu'avant il y avait des tonnes et
des tonnes de famille et une diversité
incroyable de rhinocéros aux ide dans le
registre fossile bon ben voilà c'est les
périodes acte ils vont se faire
littéralement bouffer par les arceaux
dactyle enfin bouffe est évidemment non
jeudi je devrais pas dire littéralement
bouffer vont se faire concurrencer sur
leur propre terrain par les arceaux
dactyle et tout ça c'est en connexion
avec justement le changement climatique
qui a lieu à la ligue au sen et le
changement d'environnement qui va avec
parce que les ruminants il son [ __ ] de
balèze quand il s'agit de vivre sur un
brin d'herbe
parce que là vous pouvez voir donc ce
petit diagramme il vous montre en fait
combien de ruminants sont capables de
vivre sur un seul brin d'herbe donc sur
le bras sur la partie très sèche tout en
haut du bras d'herbe vous allez avoir
les art beast vous allez avoir les
buffles et vous allez avoir donc les
chevaux bon on va les laisser de côté
parce que ce ne sont pas des ruminants
mais voilà vous avez déjà des ruminantes
de grande taille tels que les art beast
et les buffles qui vont se nourrir de la
partie haute de l'herbe donc c'est les
ruminants qui finalement sont très très
peu dépendant de l'eau dans leur
nourriture ils vont ils vont boire à
côté notamment les buffles ils vont
boire beaucoup à côté parce qu'il faut
compenser sur le fait du fait le fait
qu'ils ne mangent que les parties sèches
des plantes
ensuite quand la plante a été quand la
partie sèche des plantes a été coupée la
partie tendre un peu plus tendre au
milieu va être consommée par donc les
dames à l'isq et parler de nous donc
voilà ces espèces sont un peu moins
dépendante de l'eau de boisson
parce qu'elles ont accès à un peu plus
d'eau que les que les que les buffles
par exemple et enfin tout alla tout à la
base des plantes vous allez avoir les
plantes les plus les plantes les plus
les papas les plantes mais les pousse
les plus fraîches les et donc les plus
jeunes et aussi celles qui ont plus
d'eau qui vont servir de nourriture aux
springboks
par exemple donc voilà vous avez en tout
trois catégories d'espèces qui sont
capables de survivre sur un seul brin
d'herbe
donc c'est pour ça que vous pouvez avoir
une énorme diversité de ruminants sur la
même savane
c'est parce qu'en fait il ne mange pas
la même chose sur cette savane il ne
mange pas la même partie des herbes
sur la même savane et ça c'est quand
même assez formidable et tout ça c'est
lié à leur dépendance à l'eau en fête
s'ils sont si si ils ont une forte
indépendance à l'eau ils vont devoir
manger les petites pousses fraîches
s'ils ont une forte dépendance à l'eau
comme les buffles ils vont ils vont
pouvoir manger des les pousse plus plus
sèche et donc ça c'est assez formidable
c'est comme ça en fait que les ruminants
parviennent finalement à être aussi
diversifiée sur le même carré de pelouse
au final on quitte les ruminants on
continue à monter l'arbre phylogénétique
en direction des cétacés et on rencontre
maintenant notre première espèce
semi-aquatique les hippopotames alors
les hippopotames ils sont très faciles à
reconnaître parce qu'ils ont une gueule
ils ont vraiment une gueule ils ont une
énorme gueule parce qu'ils sont capables
de bail et donc ça c'est le bâillement
de l'hippopotame que vous voyez là et il
est permis en fait pas recette déjà par
un énorme muscles mastic ateurs que vous
pouvez voir sa tâche est ici à la
mandibule mais surtout par cette petite
encoche que vous voyez là qui fait que
quand le l'hippopotame by donc à la
google grande ouverte ici l'angle de la
mâchoire ne coupe pas la carotide donc
grâce à cette petite encoche la carotide
hop elle se glisse là dans le trou et du
coup il ne coupe pas leur carotide
enfin une coupe à la circulation
sanguine quand ils ouvrent grand leur
gueule donc ça c'est ça permet de
reconnaître immédiatement la mandibule
d'un hippopotame
évidemment vous allez reconnaître leurs
mandibules d'un hippopotame par ses
défenses des défenses formé à la fois
par les canines
mais aussi par les incisives donc c'est
les seuls à ratio d'actifs qui ont des
défenses à la fois canine et incisive et
ce sur la mâchoire inférieure et la
mâchoire supérieure et enfin les
hippopotames ont des dents ipso bruno
dhont donc un peu comme le phacochère ce
qui va donner à l'heure dans cette usure
en trèfle
en fait ça ressemble un peu à du trèfle
quoi faut avoir un peu d'imagination
mais c'est vraiment une usure très
typique dont des dents massive à usure
en trèfle typiquement des dents ipso
bruno dhont donc les hippopotames très
facile à reconnaître
et en plus ils sont semi aquatique dont
qu'ils ont
dieu en fait situé sur le sommet du
crâne et qui font pop un peu au sommet
du crâne comme ça donc si vous suivez la
ligne supérieure du crâne vous pouvez
voir que les dieux en fait y voilà il
dépasse un peu par le dessus c'est ce
qui leur permet de regarder au dessus du
niveau de l'eau en restant complètement
caché un peu comme des crocodiles en
fait donc pendant longtemps on avait un
gros gap un gros trou dans nos côtés
connaissance du registre fossile des
hippopotames parce que les premiers
hippopotames se trouvait dans le minho
scène supérieur et pardon dans le minho
scène jusque jusqu'à la fin du miocène
inférieur pardon et avant ça on n'avait
rien bon pourtant il devait bien être là
tous les autres groupes darciaux d'actes
il commence super profonde ans dans les
hauts-seine sauf les hippopotames et la
question d'hésiter mais pourquoi
pourquoi qu'on trouve pas encore
d'hippopotames dans les eaux saines et
bal à la raison c'était qu'on les avait
déjà trouvé c'est juste qu'on savait pas
que c'était des hippopotames et ce
groupe ce sont les entre à côté rider
donc les entre à côté rider vous voyez
ici un exemple mais ricco pottas mus
donc mais ricco pottas mus ces voix là
il a une bonne tête d'hippopotames il a
des grosses défenses il a des yeux qui
font pop sur le sommet du crâne il a un
très long museau
bref il ferait bon candidat pour le pour
un hippopotame ancestrales donc pourquoi
on n'a pas reconnu les ancêtres des
hippopotames immédiatement parmi ces
entraco terry des bas tout simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la bonne
morphologie dentaire et c'est là qu'on
voit l'importance de la morphologie
dentaire pour la taxonomie des
mammifères c'est que les emprunts côté
rider ils ont des dents celeno d'hondt
elle sombra qui celeno d'hondt alors que
les hippopotames idées ont des dents je
voulais dit
ipso bruno dhont donc ont manqué en fait
de manquer d'intermédiaire entre ces
deux entre ces deux types morphologiques
dentaire pour faire pour arriver à faire
cette connexion est donc cette connexion
elle a fini par être faite par des
chercheurs de poitiers et de montpellier
donc là par exemple vous avez jean reno
boisserie qui est crédité pour l'auteur
de cette image donc il ya des espèces
finalement qui dans le milieu scène
d'abord puis dans l'oligocène ont fini
par combler en fait cette lacune et nous
aurons fini par nous montrer comment on
passe dedans c'est les 90 a des dents
bruno dhont chez les hippopotames idée
donc voila c mais c'est tout sur la
morphologie dentaire en fait que le
début
le débat a été résolu parce qu'on a pu
résoudre la transition en fait de
l'homme de la morphologie dentaire et
nous arrivons donc aux cétacés
alors déjà quel caractère partagent les
hippopotames avec les cétacés bas c'est
l'heure évidemment le fait d'être semi
aquatique
mais les hippies évidemment être semi
aquatique c'est quelque chose qui arrive
et plein plein de fois dans l'évolution
des arts cieux dactyle pas seulement
chez les hippopotames
vous pouvez penser par exemple je sais
pas moi au buffle le cas justement
le buffle aquatique qui vit en asie par
exemple voilà c'est typiquement c'est
typiquement un exemple de darciaux
dactyle semi aquatique qui est pas
forcément directement connectée aux
cétacés voilà mais le fait est que les
hippopotames idées sont plus
profondément adapté au mode de vie
aquatique que n'importe quel autre art
you dactyle terrestre par le fait qu'il
qu'ils sont capables en fait d'allaiter
leurs petits sous l'eau et ça il ya qu
un seul autre groupe qui sait faire
parmi les a reçus au tactile et ce sont
les cétacés donc la sinne apomorphine
qui unirait tous ces deux groupes en
plus d'une quantité d adn en commun
gigantesque parce qu'il faut pas se
leurrer c'est évidemment l'adn est
essentiellement l'adn qui soutient qui
historiquement a commencé à soutenir un
lien de parenté entre les hippopotames
idées et les cétacés
mais au final il ya quand même quelques
caractéristiques physiologiques et
notamment cette adaptation au milieu
aquatique avec l'allaitement du petit
sous l'eau qui sont qui sont uniques aux
cétacés et aux hippopotames idées et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ça a pas
l'air d'avoir évolué de façon
convergente donc les cétacés sont bel et
bien des ongulés ne vous déplaise
on va voir l'évolution des arceaux
dactyle
en cétacés et pour ça on va commencer en
fait non pas par le début mais
directement par la fin en fait donc on
va commencer par les cétacés d'abord et
on finira sur les a reçus au tactile qui
ont donné naissance aux cétacés donc
pour ça on va diviser les cétacés en
deux groupes principaux l'un des groupes
et monofil éthique et s'appelle lesotho
set dans lequel on retrouve donc les
baleines à fanons que sont les
mysticètes et les baleines à dents que
sont mes autres dotons 7 alors les
baleines à dents qu'on appelle plus
couramment les dauphins et on va les
séparer
par opposition aux arcs et aux sept qui
sont qui est un groupe paraphe il
éthique ancêtres directs des autos sept
qui sont finalement les baleines à
quatre pattes
donc vous avez et vous avez différents
degrés de quatre attitudes j'ai envie de
dire chez les archaeocètes de
complètement quadrupèdes a quasiment
plus quadrupèdes
mais avec des petits moignon qui reste
des pâtes donc on va voir cette
évolution pas dans le détail parce que
comme je les dis la dernière fois j'ai
déjà fait une vidéo complète sur
l'évolution des cétacés
elle est en ligne jeux
si j'y pense je vous la mettrait en
descriptions voilà n'hésitez pas dans
les commentaires à me dire t'as pas mis
la vidéo en description si j'ai oublié
voilà je j'ai fait une vidéo complète
sur l'évolution des cétacés donc là on
va vraiment faire une approche qui est
différente de ma vidéo sur l'évolution
des cétacés en partant de la fin en fait
et en survolant un peu certains aspects
qui sont moins hausse théologique que
d'autres on va dire donc déjà d'où vient
cette idée que les cétacés ont un
ancêtre terrestre avant même d'avoir les
fossiles on savait déjà que les cétacés
à un ancêtre terrestre pour la simple et
bonne raison que ces abrutis ont des
poumons et qu'il n'y a rien de plus con
que d'avoir des poumons quand on vit
sous l'eau bah oui les poissons ils ont
débranché
alors les animaux qui respire qui sont
capable de respirer sous l'eau
lisez vite d'avoir des poumons parce que
sinon tu es obligé de remonter à la
surface
et là qui est ce qui t'attend des
prédateurs et oui donc et pas seulement
venant de dehors aussi venant du dessous
je vous rappelle que les la façon dont
les requins blancs chasse les cétacés
c'est en attaquant par le dessous quand
les cétacés justement remonte respirer
et la façon dont le megalodon allait
attaquer des baleines c'est pareil c'est
en attaquant par le dessous quand ils
allaient respirer bon enfin évidemment
là c'est une reconstruction basée sur le
requin blanc donc c'était en fait une
pseudo réplication de mes données
je suis en train de parler statistiques
ça veut dire que la seule leçon est
beaucoup trop longue
je perde les pédales mais bref voilà
donc quand vous êtes quand vous êtes
obligés d'aller respirer surface c'est
c'est que vous avez un problème est que
vous et que vous vivez globalement sous
l'eau c'est que vous avez un problème et
le problème des cétacés basse et qu'il
descende justement d'un ancêtre
terrestre qui leur a légué des poumons
et non pas des branchies voilà on sait
aussi qu'ils ont un ancêtre terrestre
parce qu'ils ont des caractères
typiquement malien il halète leur petit
et ils ont sept vertèbres cervicales
comme tous les mammifères
or les mammifères sont profondément
terrestre dans
de façon ancestrale il ya voilà il ya en
tout et pour tout trois groupes de
mammifères marins les cétacés les
pinnipèdes les sirénia alors qu'il y a
pléthore de groupes terrestre tout le
reste des mammifères sont terrestres
donc voilà c'est bien la condition
terrestre qui est ancestrale chez les
mammifères et c'est aussi ce que ne ce
qu'indique le registre fossile donc tout
ça pointe pointe est très clairement du
doigt le une origine terrestre des
cétacés avant même qu'on ait le moindre
faux cils de cétacés en réalité aussi
quand on regarde le bras des cétacés
donc ils ont plus de gens mais
évidemment mais quand on regarde leurs
bras bas on retrouve les mêmes unités
morphologiques que chez les autres que
sur le bras des autres mammifères et
notamment des mammifères terrestres à
savoir un stylo pod un second code et un
auto pod alors pour ceux qui parlent pas
le chinois
ça veut dire un os 2 au plat dos voilà
stylo pod and of the go pote 2 aux autos
pod plein dos donc humérus ras du sud
n'a et l'ensemble métacarpe et phalange
pour former la main donc et c'est
exactement la même structure qu'on
retrouve chez les mammifères terrestres
et même chez la chauve souris donc on
tout ça est dérivé d'un ancêtre commun
qui était terrestre parce que des pâtes
ça sert avant tout à marcher chez les
tétrapodes encore que évidemment des
gens qui étudient les amphibiens du
permien meurent contrediront de ce point
de vue enfin du carbonifère pardon et du
dévonien me contrediront de ce point de
vue là mais voilà quand on est un
mammifère le membre tétrapodes sert à
marcher alors comment reconnaît-on à
cétacés quand on envoie 1 donc on quitte
le côté les mammifères
enfin les cétacés sont des mammifères et
on entre dans le côté hamas et à ckoi
que c'est alors pour reconnaître à cet
ac quand on envoie et notamment un
fossile de cétacés quand on envoie elle
il ya plusieurs caractères qu'on peut
utiliser le premier est le plus flagrant
chez les autos 7 donc les mamies
c'est assez moderne c'est le télescopage
des os crânien
vous avez un recul des narines donc les
narines qui partent du bout du nez vont
chez les cétacés atterrir au sommet du
crâne
en fait réformer les vents mais ce recul
des narines a eu des conséquences assez
improbable sur le crâne
il ya un effet secondaire kiss cool
assez remarquable chez cétacés c'est que
vous avez un allongement de loos près
maxillaire que vous voyez en jaune ici
et un allongement de l'os maxillaire en
rouge que vous voyez ici chez l'humain
qui vont pas seulement être poussé vers
l'arrière mais vont venir complètement
recouvrir l'os frontal
donc c'est comme si vous partiez de la
est en fait au lieu de seulement pousser
l'os frontal vers l'arrière en faites
vous passer par dessus et vous le
recouvrer complètement et c'est ce que
vous voyez ici vous voyez le maxillaire
le pré maxillaire et vous voyez ici la
surface sur l'os frontal sur lequel le
spray maxillaire vient s'insérer parce
qu'il le recouvre complètement est ici
vous avez une réduction des zones azot
donc les petits hommes bleus là qui sont
finalement autour ou juste à côté de
l'évent quoi juste derrière les vents
donc c'est ce que vous voyez c'est ce
que vous voyez là les vents est ici et
là sur cette photo et ça ça a un effet
c'est un effet un autre effet kiss cool
assez remarquable c'est que le foramen
afra orbitaire donc foramen c'est un
petit trou et il est infra orbitaire ce
qui veut dire qu'il se trouve en dessous
de leurs beats donc l'orbité là le
foramen infra orbitaire est ici dans le
maxillaire
et bien ce foramen infra orbitaire chez
les cétacés
il ne se trouve pas en dessous de l'oeil
mais en réalité au dessus de l'oeil
ici vous avez l'oeil et le foramen infra
orbitaire au lieu de se trouver par là
et bien il se trouve ici sur le
maxillaire donc voilà une vue dans vue
de dessus vous avez l'oeil ici et vous
avez le foramen infra orbitaire qui se
trouve au dessus de l'oeil et ça c'est
assez prodigieux donc il est toujours
dans le maxillaire
il donne toujours passage aux mêmes
nerfs qui est le nerf
free jumeaux mais c'est mais il est
situé cette fois au dessus de leurs
beats
donc voilà il ya aussi un autre
caractère important chez les cétacés
c'est la réduction de l'os du gal donc
voilà l'arcade du gal tel qu aller chez
le war iv igomatik telle qu'elle est
chez l'être humain est bien l'os du gal
c'est plus qu'une fine baguette chez les
cétacés
mais vous voyez ici cette fine baguette
ici bien détaillé sur cette image là
vous avez aussi des modifications de la
boîte crânienne donc les eaux pariétaux
donc en verre ici envers là donc les
eaux pariétaux qui normalement se touche
au milieu du crâne il forme la voûte
crânienne les eaux pariétaux et bien ne
se touchent plus chez les cétacés vous
voyez que là ils sont complètement
séparés du coup par les maxillaires qui
ont été poussées vers l'arrière mais
aussi par nos supra occipital qui est
venu toucher les mains les naseaux vers
l'avant donc vous imaginez ça c'est l'os
supra occipital donc c'est l'équivalent
de l'occiput alsh et le chez l'humain et
cette hausse là il est parti en avant
par là tandis que le nasa lille est
parti en arrière par l'attenté si bien
que celle et ses tâches et c'est les
états à chez les cétacés
il se touche ici essayez de le redire
chez vous verrez c'est pas drôle chez
les cétacés il se touche ici c'est ce
que vous voyez là et donc comme ils se
touchent pas du coup les deux os
pariétaux sont poussées sur le côté et
vous voyez qu'ils se touchent pas là
alors ça c'est surtout vrai chez les
chez les autos c'est donc chez les
dauphins
c'est un peu moins vrai chez les
mysticètes mais ça reste enfin la
surface de contact entre les eaux
pariétaux reste très ténue chez les
mysticètes et enfin vous avez la
condition hamas tohid donc la condition
hamas tohid qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que la peau fils masto id
de l'ofsp est re ne participe plus au
crâne
qu'est ce que ça implique bas ça
implique qu'en fait le spectre eux qui
est donc losc qui contient l'oreille
interne est complètement réduit chez les
cétacés et donc est tellement petit
qu'en fait on ne le voit plus apparaître
sur la boîte crânienne
alors je vais un peu détaillé
cette partie là parce que ça des
implications importantes donc chez les
cétacés l'oreille interne est contenue
dans le spectre eux comme chez tous les
mammifères mais cet aspect trop en fait
il a besoin d'être il a besoin d' isoler
complètement l'oreille interne
pourquoi parce que si on isole pas
l'oreille interne chez un animal
aquatique qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben
les sons ils arrivent de tous les côtés
parce que la chair à la même densité que
l'eau mais du coup les hoba il vous
traversé le crâne
et arrive par tous les côtés à
l'intérieur de l'oreille au lieu
d'arriver par le côté où elle est où le
son est censé arriver c'est à dire par
le trou de l'oreille au final alors les
cétacés pour résoudre ces problèmes là
eh bien ils ont déjà ils ont plus de
trous de l'oreille le son est conduit
directement de la mâchoire dans
l'oreille
exactement comme ça se passe chez les
reptiles d'ailleurs donc ils sont
revenus au caractère un peu plus
reptilien donc la mâchoire capte les
sons transmet laissons aux tympans
tympans qui est extrêmement gros est
extrêmement dense et ce tympans va
transmettre les sons à l'oreille interne
via les les osselets que vous voyez ici
donc ça c'est classique je veux dire
mais voilà pour empêcher les sons
d'arrivée non seulement par les osselets
mais aussi par tous les autres côtés eh
ben il faut que l'oreille soit isolé et
ça ça va être ça va être accompli de
deux façons d'une il y à l'oreille le
pet re pardon va devenir extrêmement
dense presque aussi dense que l'émail
donc c'est ce que vous voyez ici ce qui
va du coup lui permettre de se préserver
très facilement donc l'osce petros est
généralement le truc que vous retrouvez
en plus grande abondance si vous
cherchez du fossile de cétacés parce que
comme il est aussi dense que l'émail en
fait ils sont aussi commun que des dents
donc le spectre eux va être extrêmement
dense ce qui va permettre aux sont
finalement de ne pas rentrer directement
à travers le
la texture osseuse de l'osce petros ça
va obliger les sons à faire le tour
est-ce qu'il va encore plus obliger les
sons à faire le tour c'est que le
spectre eux ne va pas être attachés au
crâne
l'os petrova arrêter de faire partie du
crâne et va finalement être isolé par un
sinus donc c'est ce qui s'appelle le
sinus père hibulaire donc comme le
spectre se rétracte du crâne et bien il
ne participe plus à la boîte crânienne
d'où la masse tohidi d'où l'absence
d'apophis masto id du pétrole dans le
crâne donc l'apophyse mastocytes ce
serait normalement à diverticules qu'il
irait par la cua et là il vous le voyez
il n'existe pas donc de cette façon le
son ne peut pas rentrer par là il est
obligé de rentrer par la mâchoire donc
par ce morceau de grèce qui vient
directement de la mâchoire inférieure et
pouf dans les osselets et direction
l'oreille interne et grâce à ça ils sont
capables d'entendre d'où viennent les
sons malgré le fait qu'ils vivent sous
l'eau et ça c'est beau c'est quand même
vachement beau donc ça ça s'appelle donc
là l'extrême densité du pétrole c'est ce
qu'on appelle une pâquis aux stones en
fait on devrait même dire une pâquis
ostéo sclérose mais là ça commence à
vraiment à faire beaucoup de syllabes et
c'est relou donc là pas qui c'est pour
l'épaisseur et ostéo sclérose c'est pour
la densité donc une pâquis ostéo
sclérose de l'oreille et pas seulement
du pétrole mais aussi de la bulle et la
bulle est là cette espèce de grosse
épaississement que vous pouvez voir ici
la bulletin panique en coupe cette
espèce de gros et spécisme ans ça
s'appelle la vo lu crom et sa garde et
le bien dans un petit coin de votre tête
parce qu on en reparlera de l'invs au
lucre sommes donc la très forte densité
des os de l'oreille caractère typique
des cétacés avec une belle grosse buse
une belle grosse bulletin panique bien
épaisse et bien dense avec un aveu luc
rome
gardez bien ça en tête on en reparlera
et donc l'application en fait pratique
de cette très forte densité osseuse bas
c'est que dans les dépôts marc dans les
dépôts aquatiques notamment marins du
du milieu scène notamment et du pliocène
et du pléistocène bon vous allez trouver
à balles de gros aux biens danse comme
cela et ben ça c'est des bulletins
panique en fait de cétacés au milieu des
dents megalodon d'ailleurs vous pouvez
voir de belles dents de megalodon ici
donc voilà ça ça fait qu'on va trouver
plein dos de l'oreille moyenne de ces
cétacés
alors c'est parti pour l'évolution des
cétacés en commençant par la fin donc en
commun si on commence par la fin on
commence par donc les hôtes hausse est
donc dauphins cachalots orques et j'en
passe et des meilleurs donc tous les
cétacés qui ont encore des dents qu'on
oppose aux mysticètes c'est à dire les
baleines à fanons qui n'ont plus de
dents mais qui ont des fans on a la
place alors ses fans on se sont pas des
dents ce sont en fait des poils qui
pousse sur le palais les dents
complètement disparu chez les mysticètes
encore que quand on dissèque un
mysticètes juvénile
on peut voir à l'intérieur de sa
mâchoire des petites cavités qui
corresponde finalement à l'endroit où
les dents auraient dû pousser au final
donc voilà les mysticètes non plus
dedans mais par contre elle on ses poils
que sont les fans on est elle les
utilise pour filtrer l'eau alors vous
avez deux types de mysticètes vous avez
les mysticètes qui écument l'eau
typiquement les les baleines franches et
vous avez les mysticètes qui engouffre
l'eau et qui ensuite avec donc ils l ont
cette espèce de gorge extensible avec
des sillons de suez en fait elles sont
capables de d'engouffrer beaucoup d'eau
comme un pélican et ensuite de
contracter les muscles de la gorge pour
vider l'eau à travers leurs fans ont
justement
et comme salo en ressortant finalement
est filtrée et la nourriture et garder à
l'intérieur de leur bouche
donc ça ça leur permet finalement de ne
pas être obligé de rester tout le temps
au même niveau comme le font les et
crémeuse donc la baleine bleue la
baleine à bosse typiquement sondés
engouffre heureuse c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi des baleines aubeterre
parce qu'ils ont des
les embauches reuze sont des baleines
aubeterre elles ont des très longues de
très longues
palette natatoire avec de multiples
phalanges et seulement quatre doigts
donc voilà les baleines bleues
typiquement sondés engouffre heureuse et
les mysticètes sont aussi reconnaissable
parce que leur maxillaire donc du coup
vu qu'elle on s'est vu qu'elles ont ces
espèces de ba de fanon il leur faut une
surface palatine très grandes surfaces
du palais qui leur est fournie par le
maxillaire donc c'est ce que vous voyez
ici le maxillaire ici était tendue
latéralement il forma une sorte de
plateau alors petit rajout remontage
parce que je me suis un peu emmêlé les
pinceaux un moment en fait donc je
disais que ceux ci étaient les
maxillaires et ce sont effectivement les
maxillaires donc les maxillaires sont
télescopés vers l'arrière comme ils sont
censés l'être chez les cétacés
ici vous avez les prêts maxillaire et
donc c'est au maxillaire ici forment une
très grande surface d'assertions pour
les pour les fans on que vous voyez ici
donc c'est bien sûr ces grands plateaux
maxillaire que vont s'étendre les fanons
et vous pouvez même voir ici des petites
des petites ponctuation ici qui sont
autant de vaisseau en fait qui servent à
irriguer le museau et à innerver le
museau des
des mysticètes et vous pouvez voir les
mêmes de l'autre côté je vous montrerai
une photo un petit peu plus loin où vous
verrez des petits canaux similaire de
l'autre côté sur la face palatine qui
apportent la nourriture pour faire
grandir ses fans ont parce que ses fans
ont évidemment sur comme des cheveux se
renouvelle tout au long de la vie est
ici vous avez des grands plateaux formé
par les eaux qui sont les frontaux voilà
donc ça ce sont les eaux frontaux donc
vous avez peut-être m'entendre dire par
moment qu'il s'agit en fait d au
maxillaire
après c'est parce que je me suis un peu
embrouillé ne vous trompez pas il s'agit
bien des eaux frontaux et les au
maxillaire sont ici on croirait que
c'est les yeux mais en fait c'est pas du
tout les yeux ici un de la baleine les
yeux ils sont là voyez là on vous voyez
ce petit renfoncement là dans le
maxillaire l'oeil
il est là en réalité mais ça c'est pas
les yeux de la baleine en fait c'est
juste le maxillaire
et là vous pouvez voir le supra
occipital voiliers qui justement c'est
par les mots pariétaux de chaque côté
donc c'est très bizarrement foutu une
baleine est donc un par opposition aux
baleines à fanons bas on a les baleines
qui ont des dents donc qui n'ont pas
toujours des dents d'ailleurs puisque
les baleines à bec sont un exemple
un contre exemple flagrant de baleines
de baleines à dents qui n'ont pas de
dents donc bon bref voilà c'est pour ça
que j'aime mieux dire les dauphins même
si les dauphins sont en réalité un petit
groupe d'auto 7 mais j'aime bien dire
dauphin la place d'auto 7
parce que je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais je galère à dire
odontocètes c'est très très dur à
prononcer pour moi je sais pas pourquoi
mon cerveau a décidé qu'il n'arriverait
pas à prononcer ce mot donc ces autos 7
il se caractérise par le fait qu'ils
sont capables de faire de l'écholocation
donc ils produisent des ultrasons ils
sont capables d'entendre ces ultrasons
pour se repérer exactement comme des
chauves souris ou un sous marin et 2
fait de cet éco location et bien leur
crâne est extrêmement déformés parce que
les colocations s'accompagne de la
présence d'un organe qui s'appelle le
melon et qui est un organe de tissus
mous qui se trouvent ici sur le crâne et
qui prend beaucoup de place du coup les
eaux d'auto 7 n'ont qu'un seul et vend
donc le beau rôle s'élévant en anglais
donc ils n'ont qu'un seul et vent
contrairement aux mysticètes qui ont
deux évents donc les mysticètes on a
crâne bien symétrique
alors que les autos 7 vous pouvez voir
ont un crâne asymétrique donc ici ça se
voit particulièrement baer sur les zone
naso veysonnaz zones ne sont pas
symétriques et c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont cassés c'est vraiment à ça que ça
ressemble le crâne n'est pas symétrique
parce qu'il ya un trou que d'un côté en
fait il n'y a qu'un seul
il n'y a qu'une seule narines en fait et
ça c'est parce que le melon prend
beaucoup de place et c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya toute une machinerie pour
produire les cliques qui permettent de
faire les colocations donc il faut
produire des clics sur aiguë et ses
petits clics suraigu ils sont produits
dans une machinerie qui se trouvent par
là et qui a aussi des effets secondaires
la présence de cette machinerie de
prendre la place et à des effets
secondaires sur la morphologie les autos
sept ont aussi
donc ils ont des dents mais les dents ne
sont pas n'importe comment
elles sont toutes les mêmes donc c'est
fini la différenciation entre incisive
canine prémolaires et molères tout ça
c'est fini toutes les danses sont les
mêmes et toutes les dents sont
généralement en forme de harpon donc
juste une boîte assez acérées pour
attraper le poisson et ses dents ne se
renouvelle
jamais donc là le fait que les dents se
renouvellent est appelée dit fier aux
dons ci s est une caractéristique des
mammifères on en reparlera dans
l'évolution des synapses id mais cette
diffuse aussi chez les cétacés chez les
cétacés odontocètes est remplacée par
une mono fille aux dons si donc il n'y a
qu'une seule génération dedans il n'y a
plus de remplacement dentaire donc voilà
ils naissent lors damphousse et elle ne
repousse jamais voit la fin de
l'histoire est généralement vous avez
alors side toutes les dents n'ont pas
disparu comme chez les baleines à bec
vous avez aussi beaucoup plus de dents
que vous n'êtes censé en à voir donc
notamment vous n'a comme vous n'avez pas
un conte de molaire fixe en fait il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de dents vous regardez
un dauphin vous pouvez pas compter 3
molaires 4 prémolaires une canine et 3,3
perdre incisive ça c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche un dauphin un dauphin
c'est plein dedans qui sont toutes les
mêmes
et le conte ne colle pas avec un compte
de dans deux formules dentaire de
mammifères normal en fait
alors maintenant on va commencer à
voyager dans le passé donc on va garder
les mêmes groupes mais on part dans le
passé donc du côté oddo tôt celle de la
force
on a toujours des baleines à dents des
mets qui ont un crâne déjà qui est
beaucoup moins déformée par le melon qui
devait être beaucoup plus petit beaucoup
moins déformée par les colocations
puisqu'il n'est pas asymétrique donc
vous vous avez un crâne maintenant qui
est totalement symétrique voici échos
venator de l'oligocène d'amérique du
nord et ceux échos venator et bien il a
un crâne beaucoup plus un peu plus
primitifs puisque les eaux déjà sont
beaucoup moins télescoper vers l'arrière
la fosse pour accueillir le melon est
moins développée et du coup le crâne est
beaucoup plus symétrique est ce qu'on
reconnaît chez eco venator c'est surtout
les terreaux dont six maintenant alors
vous avez toujours pas dedans que vous
pouvez difficilement à plessé dans des
molaires mais si vous êtes vraiment
imaginatif vous pouvez appeler ses dents
des molaires et ses molaires ont une
forme triangulaire ce sont des dents
triangulaire et crénelés qui sont qui
sont finalement des dents de super
prédateur au final un cd cd tronçonneuse
c'est des tronçonneuses sur sur racine
quoi mais vous avez aussi à l'avant donc
vous avez maintenant une dentition
antérieur une dentition postérieur donc
ça c'est on revient vers le léthé ronde
aussi primitif des mammifères et de
l'autre côté donc du côté mysticètes de
la force j'ai envie de dire eh bien on a
des animaux tels que corot nos dons dans
l'oligocène et on a même des mysticètes
maintenant jusque dans les eaux seine
dans les hauts-seine supérieur donc on a
même des mysticètes de l'éocène qui ont
tous cette particularité bien d'avoir
comme les mysticètes moderne un max
hilaire étendue et le frontal qui à
cette forme rectangulaire comme on a vu
tout à l'heure chez le mysticètes
moderne donc donc un crâne qui est
définitivement celui d'un mysticètes
mais avec vous voyez le la narine qui
n'est pas aussi enfin les narines qui ne
sont pas aussi reculé que chez les
mysticètes moderne et notamment vous
avez les eaux pariétaux ici vous voyez
ils se touchent les eaux pariétaux alors
que si on regarde le mysticètes de tout
à l'heure voyez qui si vous avez le
supra occipital qui vient toucher les
aux naseaux ici donc les pariétaux n'ont
qu'un contact très limité à ce niveau là
encore il ya une grande surface de
contact entre les eaux pariétaux qui
forment une belle crête sagittale donc
ça c'est un beau caractère bien primitif
et un autre caractère primitif bien plus
notable de ce mysticètes est bien c'est
que cette baleine à fanons n'a pas de
fans ont par contre elle a des dents
essaie d'envoyer elles sont pas
organisés n'importe comment
ce sont des dents triangulaire et
crénelés donc là vous voyez très bien
les créneaux mur ici donc ce sont ces
décret de murs exagéré c'est la même
morphologie que les dents triangulaire
et crée des décors et n'a tort mais
organisé d'une façon différente donc ici
il ya un petit chevauchement entre
chaque dent qui permet de filtrer l'eau
en fête donc ses dents elles sont
utilisées en compensation de l'absence
des fans on est en réalité j'ai presque
envie de dire que vu qu'on travaille en
marche arrière
la vérité c'est que les fans ont évolué
en compensation de ses dents donc c'est
les fans ont qui ont fini par remplacer
les dents donc il ya c'est un système en
fait les fans ont les le système de
chevauchement des dents a finalement
servi de système
on va dire 1.0 au système des fanons 2.0
et il ya très probablement eu un
chevauchement entre les deux systèmes
comme l'indiquent itunes et us qui
associe à la fois donc de belles dents
mais aussi un maxi l'air très étendue
avec des petits canaux qui permettait
d'apporter d'apporter de la nourriture
aux fans ont qui grandissait sans cesse
donc chez itunes et us qui vivaient
aussi à l'oligocène mais cette fois en
amérique du sud
eh bien vous avez l'association à la
fois dedans et de fans ont donc ça c'est
assez formidable
on a une très belle documentation très
très belle très belle transition en fait
d'un système de d'un système à un autre
mais les deux systèmes en fait
permettent d'accomplir la même tâche qui
est la filtration de l'eau et ça c'est
quand même assez merveilleux donc hélas
vous sentez venir le pattern normalement
donc écho venator qui comme son nom
l'indiqué était aussi une baleine qui
perd qui pouvaient enfin un cétacé qui
faisait les colocations on voit ici
l'oreille interne reconstitué à partir
justement de l'ofsp est re échos venator
qui est définitivement un au dos est
donc et et koro nom qui est
définitivement à mysticètes comme en
témoigne son anatomie crânienne et bien
ces deux cétacés ont en commun cette
morphologie dentaires les triangles
créneau et donc le pattern que vous
devriez sentir dès maintenant et bien
c'est que l'ancêtre commun finalement de
ces deux
ligne est l'ancêtre commun des autos
sept devaient posséder cette même
dentition avec des grosses dents
molaires entre guillemets triangulaire
et crénelés ce qui nous amène tout
naturellement aux arcs et ossètes les
plus dérivés que sont les bases ils
osent au rider et que vous connaissez
très certainement 2d reportage de la bbc
notamment donc la terre la terre à
l'époque des monstres dans un marché
walking with beast en anglais alors
c'est sur la terre des géants
si je me rappelle bien la traduction en
français donc sur la terre des géants
mais aussi il y avait nigel marven qui
avait fait les plus grands prédateurs
marins donc voilà vous devez
certainement connaître basilosaurus à
partir de ces de ces différents
reportages donc basilosaurus et bien
c'est typique c'est ça a longtemps été
on va dire l'archéo cette typique parce
que ça a longtemps été le seul archéos
est connu en réalité ça a été le premier
archéo cette découverte
d'abord en amérique puis en egypte donc
là vous avez un et jantes un exemple de
basilosaurus égyptien et alors là où il
est formidable basilosaurus c'est qu'ils
associent vraiment des caractères de
cétacés a des caractères primitif donc
déjà les caractères de cétacés c'est
évidemment son corps un très long corps
complètement fuselées a complètement
hydrodynamique donc définitivement celui
d'un cétacé avec les dernières vertèbres
de la queue qui sont en forme de boule
est pas en forme de vertèbres vertèbres
donc qui montre qu'il avait une nageoire
caudale
vous avez un des narines en position des
vents intermédiaire j'ai envie de dire
dans quelle sont pas les vents n'est pas
au-dessus de l'oeil
il n'est pas aussi loin que chez les
cétacés modernes mais il n'est pas non
plus en position terminal au bout du
museau donc un évent qui est finalement
en position intermédiaire chez
basilosaurus vous avez une arcade jus
galles qui vous pouvez le voir est
fragile mais complète je le dire c'est
pas une petite baguette osseuse comme
celle et comme chez les cétacés modernes
mais elle est quand même relativement
fines donc ça ça fait lui aussi un
cétacé est donc le caractère qu'il
partage avec les autos 7
bazot que je vous ai montré bien ce sont
ces grosses molaires triangulaire ces
grosses molaires de super prédateur donc
à partir desquels et bien les dents
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure celle des co
venator et celle de corneau dont ont
évolué donc c'est vraiment le fil rouge
la morphologie des molaires comme pour
tous les mammifères finalement la
morphologie des molaires c'est le fil
rouge de l'évolution des cétacés
voilà et après vous avez des caractère
primitif donc le bras le bras un coude
qui est mobile donc normalement le coude
et immobile chez les cétacés parce que
les bras sont transformés en palettes
natatoire donc il n'y a plus de mobilité
mais là le coude est toujours mobile
chez basilosaurus donc ça c'est un
caractère primitif est évidemment le
caractère primitif de basilosaurus qui
fait de lui un archaeocètes c'est qu'il
a quatre jambes
et oui ce petit truc là c'est ce que
vous voyez ici en plus grosse et un
fémur un radius ulna et une main à trois
doigts donc une hausse de zoo est plein
dos voici la jambe de basilosaurus
mesdames et messieurs donc voilà c'est
assez c'est assez
c'est assez formidable de voir de voir
cet exemple de basilosaurus qui a le
corps finalement d'un cétacé le corps
d'une baleine j'ai même envie de dire
avec ses petites jambes encore accrocher
dessus et donc ça c'est grandiose et
basilosaurus on n'y a vraiment aucun
doute que ses jambes sont associés à
basilosaurus parce qu en egypte on
trouve des dizaines de squelettes de
basilosaurus dans cet endroit qui
s'appelle la vallée des baleines
justement donc c'est dans la c'est dans
le fayoum c'est à côté des pyramides a
vraiment enfin je veux dire
l'egypte est un grand pays et le fayoum
se trouve vraiment à côté des pyramides
de gizeh quoi donc on sait même que les
égyptiens antiques ramassait déjà des
fossiles dans le fayoum et les eaux et
les données en offrande à leur dieu dans
des temples donc le fayoum c'est
vraiment
voilà j'ai envie de dire c'est une
grosse randonnée à côté des pyramides de
gizeh les d'ailleurs c'est basilosaurus
date de l'oligocène et il y à d'autres
baleines de la vallée des baleines qui
datent même d'un peu avant à l'eocène et
le lait les pyramides sont elles mêmes
fêtes de nu militent donc les numides ce
sont des genres de petits coquillages
c'est des foraminifères en réalité donc
c'est du ces du calcaire and humilité ce
calcaire and humilité lui aussi de
l'éocène il vient du lutétien donc c'est
pour vous dire que voilà la vallée de
l'endroit où ont été construits les
pyramides en fait c'est un grand bassin
sédimentaire éocène oligocène et dans ce
même bassin sédimentaire en fait il y
avait une mangrove autrefois dans lequel
ont vécu et sont morts des baleines et
maintenant on appelle cet endroit la
vallée des baleines
voilà vous avez la vallée des rois et la
vallée des baleines à côté c'est
merveilleux et un autre truc à propos de
ces archaeocètes c'est que là où tous
les laouchez les cétacés modernes vous
avez une diversité de régime alimentaire
les mysticètes son plan que town of ages
et les arcs et les autres autos 7 sont
macrophages donc ils mangent du poisson
quoi et des invertébrés et bien les arcs
et au 7e sont tous des prédateurs voire
même des méga prédateurs comme
basilosaurus des tops prédateurs des
super prédateur choisissez le mot que
vous voulez on continue à marcher en
arrière dans l'évolution des cétacés
donc là on va commencer à toucher à des
animaux qui ressemble vraiment plu du
tout à des cétacés mais qui partagent
toujours des caractères avec nos cétacés
plus dérives et donc le caractère qu'on
va suivre c'est évidemment la
morphologie dentaire vous voyez ici
maiacetus qui nous vient de l'eocène
moyen du moyen-orient et maiacetus a
toujours cette dentition 7 dentition
parfaitement cette acn donc triangulaire
et crénelés très typique des cétacés est
ici vous voyez lost un panique donc la
bulle tympanique très grosse et très
dense donc très typique des cétacés donc
il n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que
maiacetus est un cétacé
c'était un animal semi aquatique on le
sait grâce à des analyses isotopiques et
morphologiques vous pouvez voir le bras
de maiacetus est assez semblable à celui
de de basile aux eaux russes est alors
ce qu'il ya de formidable avec maiacetus
c'est qu'ils se
cet arc et ossètes qui fait partie de la
famille des protos cette idée a été
retrouvé avec un bébé un bébé dans le
ventre
donc c'est pas qu'il la manger parce que
vous voyez il n'a pas été digérée il est
encore articuler
non non c'est un bébé en gestation et
pas à n'importe quel moment de la
gestation puisque vous voyez il est très
grosse bébé il est mature et il est prêt
à sortir et on peut voir sur ce bébé des
dents de lait et ça ça veut dire que
chez les protos cette idée là le
renouvellement dentaire n'était pas mono
chiots dont tu m'aides if you don't donc
c'est le caractère primitif donc voilà
on est encore un peu plus proche des des
mammifères standard on va dire avec
maiacetus parce qu'on a cette diffusion
dont 6 et l'autre caractère intéressant
chez maiacetus bas c'est la position du
bébé le bébé est prêt à sortir tête la
première
or vous savez que chez les dauphins et
les baleines
le bébé sort là que la première donc ça
c'est encore un caractère primitif des
archaeocètes comme proto comme l'epo en
fin des protos cette idée est de 7
archaeocètes qui est maiacetus donc
voyage maiacetus ça veut dire la mer
baleine donc cette mère baleine donné
naissance sur terre parce que c'est pour
ça que les mammifères que les mammifères
marins modernes donne naissance avec la
queue la première c'est parce que s'il
sort la tête la première le bébé et qui
restent coincés bas ils se noient pas ce
qu'il se retrouve avec son évent
directement dans la flotte
or s'il sort là que la première balle il
voit là le quand sa tête sort il peut
tout de suite aller nager vers la
surface
parce que sa queue est déjà sorti depuis
longtemps de toute façon donc voilà mais
ici si vous avez la tête qui sort en
premier
bah fatalement vous risquez de vous
noyer si vous donnez pas naissance sur
l'eau et ce qu'on sait des protos cette
idée c'est que contrairement aux bases
il autorise des il avait des grosses
pattes arrière alors bon c'est pas pour
ce qu'il ya de préserver du fémur et du
tibia chez maiacetus qu'on le sait mais
on notre squelette complet comme celui
d'euros d'ot sais-tu ce qui est aussi un
proto cette idée et qui a de très
grosses jambes
à l'arrière on en connaît aussi un
cétacé du nom de perrigo cetus je peux
vous renvoyez encore une fois je peux
mettre un lien vers une autre vidéo que
j'ai fait qu'ils étaient une interview
de olivier lambert qui étudie justement
les cétacés et qui nous avait parlé
justement de perrigo sais tu ce qui est
un proto cette idée est évidemment vous
pouvez aussi vous référer à mon âme on
court plus complet sur l'évolution des
cétacés pour en savoir plus sur les
proto cette idée d'ailleurs je parlais
déjà de maiacetus dedans donc voilà
maiacetus et plus primitifs encore que
basilosaurus à bien des égards mais est
bel et bien connecté à basilosaurus par
la morphologie de ses dents et de son
teint panique on continue à aller en
arrière et on tombe enfin sur le très
célèbre pas qui c'est us et alors là pas
qui c'est us c'est un gros morceau parce
que alors il est formidable pas qui
c'est us il est aussi connecté à
basilosaurus et aux baleines moderne et
aux cétacés modernes pas par la
morphologie de ses dents donc dans
triangulaire et crénelés un jeu je vous
refais pas le tableau et par la
morphologie de sa bulletin panique donc
ici vous avez là bulletin panique de pas
qui c'est us
elle est très très grosse très épaisse
donc c'est une danse c'est une
bull tympanique qui est pas qu' au sto
tic donc ya pas de doute sur le fait que
pas qui c'est us est connecté à un proto
cette idée qui est connecté aussi à
basilosaurus etc ça y'a pas de doute là
dessus mais ce qu'on n'achète pas qui
c'est us donc ces quatre jambes bien
développée avec notamment sur les quatre
jambes quatre membres bien développée
avec sur les pattes arrière une
astragale avec une poulie proximale et
une poulie distale l'astragale à double
poulies des ars yoda xil mesdames et
messieurs pas qui c'est us l'ars you
dactyle avec des dents de super
prédateurs aquatiques
talât le voilà le voilà donc la
combinaison de caractère ultime qui
montre que les cétacés sont descendants
des arceaux dactyle sais pas qui c'est
us et pas qui c'est us on s'est même
qu'il était semi aquatique alors là il
est reconstituée avec des avec d'une
pâle mur sur les pieds c'est du folklore
c'est du folklore mais c'est du folklore
raisonnable parce que il comme les
hippopotames
il a les yeux au sommet du crâne comme
vous pouvez le voir les yeux sont pas
sur le côté du crâne
ils font voilà ils font pop sur le
sommet du crâne quand on le regarde de
côté donc il avait certainement un mode
de vie semi-aquatique probablement
proche des crocodiles peut-être qu'il
était capable comme les crocodiles
d'entendre avec la mâchoire inférieure
donc ça se veut si je vous dis ça c'est
pour faire directement référence à ce
qu'on vous dit dans boulot c'est us dans
le reportage sur la terre des monstres
disparu donc on voit en bulot cetus qui
se promènent en allemagne d'ailleurs
c'est une connerie ça je m'inscris en
faux
ambühl hausse et us pas qui c'est us et
tout l'origine des cétacés avant les
proto cette idée se passe dans sur le
sous continent indien et notamment au
pakistan les proto cette idée on les
retrouve un peu en dehors de l'inde aux
deux du continent
du sous continent indien donc ici par
exemple dans le maillage et us a été
retrouvé au moyen-orient les protos et
idées les plus des arrivées comme protos
et tu sers au dos et us on les retrouve
en afrique et en amérique du nord
donc ils ont déjà traversé l'atlantique
chez les protos ity dia les plus dérivés
mais pas qui c'est us et en bulles au
site us n'ont jamais quitté l'anneau
pakistan donc en bouleau cetus en
allemagne c'est du folklore c'est du
folklore c'est mignon bah en même temps
l'allemagne
ils ont le gisement de mais celle qui
est juste magnifique c'est un gisement à
préservation la guerre staaten donc
c'est un gisement à préservation
exceptionnelles tissus mous et c'est le
problème c'est que comme ils ont pas de
cétacés il pouvait pas parler de
l'évolution des cétacés et je pense
qu'ils avaient très envie très envie de
le faire parce que l'évolution des
cétacés c'est quand même un exemple
c'est en anglais on appelle ça un
exemple textbook quoi c'est un exemple
typique qu'on trouve dans tous les
bouquins quoi donc parler de l'éocène
sans parler de l'origine des cétacés ça
fait mal au cul et je pense que c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont un peu fait rentrer
en bus l'os et us dans leurs épisodes au
chausse pied parce qu'on peut pas parler
de l'éocène sans parler de mécènes mais
on peut pas non plus parler de l'éocène
sans parler d'eux
de l'évolution des cétacés et le
problème c'est que les deux ont eu lieu
à deux endroits différents mais c'est
elle c'est l'allemagne et les cétacés
c'est pakistan à l'eocène donc voilà
mais bref je m'égare un peu voilà en
ambulance et tu sais pas qui c'est us
sont globalement memni plus ou moins au
même niveau
de morphologie je veux dire il n'y a pas
grand chose de différent ambühl hausse
et us on n'a pas encore de preuves qu'il
avait une astra gala double poulies mais
on a de bonnes raisons de croire que les
protos cette idée avait encore une astra
gala double police qui veut dire cambulo
cetus comme ambulance et u7 entre les
deux il devait être à peu près il devait
être à peu près pareil donc si vous
voulez savoir tout ce qui caractérise en
bulot cetus une fois de plus j'en parle
dans mon épisode spécial sur l'évolution
des cétacés donc allé le voir si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur bulot cetus je
n'en parlerai pas ici
par contre je retourne encore plus en
arrière dans l'arbre évolutif
parce que en même temps que pas qui
c'est us vivait un do in us
donc on est allé au seine inférieure du
pakistan et un dos nu c'est bien il a
tout du dia codexis il a absolument tout
du dia codexis donc vous pouvez voir le
squelette d'un domicile à la longue que
le dos courbé il à l'astragale à double
poulies bien sûr c'est un art sio
dactyle comme dia codexis il a des
grosses dents car et c'est un c'est un
herbivore ce n'est il n'a pas des dents
trio triangulaire mais contrairement à
dia codexis 1,12 us
il a une bulle tympanique supermassive
et patriotique pâquis ostéo sclérotique
comme à cétacés modernes et comme pas
qui c'est us et sur sept bulletins
panique il y a un un volume chrome
exactement comme les cétacés modernes
donc elle n'est pas seulement pas qui
est statique elle a en plus
l'épaississement typique des cétacés
modernes donc vous pouvez voir à les
préserver des deux côtés sur le crâne
donc on a un très beau crâne d'un doji
du ce est donc ce débat c'est un dollar
us
c'est ni plus ni moins qu'un qu'india
codexis c'est-à-dire un art sio dactyle
typique de l'éocène avec un caractère
qu'on ne retrouve normalement que chez
les cétacés donc ce qui fait de 1,12 us
le plus c'est assez 1 de tous les arts
cieux dactyle possible c'est à dire que
là ou pas qui c'est us il a déjà le
profil la tête finalement que qu'auront
les proto cette idée et les
et les bases il autorise des 1 de l'us
lui il a tout de la ratio d'actifs donc
voilà une reconstruction d'un de linus
telle console représente donc c'est un
petit arthur dactyle tout ce qu'il ya de
plus de plus a reçus au tactile vous
pouvez voir ses petites pattes c'est pas
des griffes c'est des sabots il est
reconstruit comme étant par axones ya ce
qu'on voit très bien sur le squelette
est en fait il est reconstruit
semi-aquatique pourquoi déjà parce que
ça bulletin panique et paquillo staut x
qui est une adaptation à l'audition sous
l'eau mais aussi parce qu'on a fait des
sections de son de ses membres donc de
ces fémur et de cesu mary c'est qu'en
fait ces eaux sont extrêmement épais et
danse ce qu'il veut ce qui leur permet
d'agir comme des ballasts et ça on ne le
retrouve que chez les mammifères
semi-aquatique donc un do you c'était
très probablement semi aquatique et il
devait très fortement ressembler à un
oeil et moscou ce qui est un chevreau ta
semi-aquatique moderne donc les emos cus
rappelez vous c'est un trac eu l'idée
donc c'est le chevreau ta aquatique et
ce et ceux chevrotin aquatique iba il a
les mêmes traits que 1,10 us du point de
vue de ses zones ont donc de son fémur
et de numerus il a aussi des os longs
qui sont très épais et danse et qui
agissent comme des ballasts et alors
pour lui c'est pas tellement parce qu'il
a envie d'aller brouter les algues au
fond de l'eau c'est surtout parce que ça
lui permet finalement de se cacher des
prédateurs en fait les chevrotins sont
des animaux extrêmement peureux
et puis parce qu'ils sont extrêmement
sujet à la prédation je veux dire
évidemment c'est de tout petits animaux
donc vous voyez ça lui permet de marcher
au fond de l'eau et et c'est pour ça que
1,10 us est ici reconstruit très
semblables ayé moss cus le chevrotin
aquatique
vous voyez il ya tout un il ya touché
chez un ado lui si si qui rappelle le
chevreau tâche même je rêve même pas
surpris qu'ils aient utilisé précisément
cette vidéo de national geographic pour
faire cette reconstruction la dinde aux
innus vous voyez il est capable de
rester au fond de l'eau et ça c'est
grâce à ces eaux hyper dense en fait
et alors pour ceux que cela surprendrait
que dès que les mammifères que des
mammifères herbivores comme un do in us
ait pu devenir carnivores ben je vous
pointerait du doigt les nombreux
exemples de deux darciaux dactyle qui se
nourrissent une fois de temps en temps
vous gobez un petit oiseau
les vaches dans les prés si elle
rencontre un noise and i d'un oiseau qui
a nichées au sol elles vont pas se
priver de bouffer les e1
ça fait un petit apport en protéines en
plus alors elles vont pas évidemment à
manger de trop parce que évident elles
sont pas capables de digérer les
protéines animales tant que ça mais vous
voyez là la girafe là elle s'est chopé
un piaf et puis cela les arrange pas et
puis il ya on voit tous les hivers au
canada des exemples de cervidés qui
mangent du poisson et qui d'ailleurs
traverse traverse les rivières donc
voilà semi aquatique et puis si fort
c'est le début de l'évolution des
cétacés tel qu'on se l'imaginent voilà
et tout ça est lié évidemment est
profondément lié aux comptes sous
continent indien et notamment à la
collision du sous continent indien avec
l'asie qui au début de l'éocène et au
paléo scène donc parce que évidemment
l'évolution des cétacés a dû commencer
déjà bien avoir un deux minutes pascal
dolfus déjà une oreille une oreille de
mammifères semi aquatique
vous voyez que le sous continent indien
il est rentré en collision avec l'asie
donc déjà dès la fin du crétacé et était
bien en collision au paléo scène et cela
a formé durant le paléocène eocène et
bad et des zones en fait de marécageuse
plus ou moins dos en fait finalement dde
plein de petits lacs de lagune
deux zones où finalement des mammifères
semi-aquatique était très très favorisés
quoi au final donc beaucoup de
ressources
si on sait exploiter un milieu semi
aquatique donc d'où l'évolution des
cétacés dans cette région là en inde au
pakistan à l'époque de l'éocène et puis
ici c'est pour vous récapitule et tout
un tas de tendance évolutif chez les
cétacés alors encore une fois je vous
invite à aller voir ma vidéo mon cours
sur les cétacés pour en savoir plus mais
c'est pour vous montrer que l'évolution
des cétacés est intimement corrélée à
l'évolution du climat donc la première
glaciation ici à l'oligocène donc le
courant circumpolaire provoque un boost
de diversification des cétacés et
notamment des mysticètes parce que qui
dit courant circumpolaire dhikr il un le
courant circumpolaire créé des zones de
up welling qui ramène des nutriments à
la surface donc il ya du krill qui va
qui va proliférer et évidemment les
mysticètes vont se gaver de ce crime
donc voilà le apparition du courant
circumpolaire égale radiation des
mysticètes réchauffement durant le mieux
aux scènes égale radiation des hautes
eaux cette
donc est évidemment qui dit mammifères
marins dit prédateurs des mammifères
marins donc le megalodon mais aussi
d'autres mammifères marins comme le
livia temps melville et le fameux
cachalot géant bouffeurs de baleines
donc voila tout tout est lié
j'ai envie de dire tout est lié pour peu
qu'on se penche un peu sur les
sur les différents corps et là j'ai
envie de dire et ici voilà une
récapitulation la tendance à la recul de
l'évent tendance à la réduction des
pâtes à la au corps qui devient de plus
en plus aérodynamique hydrodynamique
pardon ici évolution des fans on chez
les mysticètes donc voilà c'est juste
pour vous récapitule est un peu secours
ce qui nous amène à la fin de cette
partie sur les arceaux dactyle et au
début de la partie sur les persos
dactyle donc ça fait un peu plus d'une
heure qu'on est ensemble
c'est le moment d'aller chercher un café
ou une boisson fraîche selon le temps
qui fait c'est le moment d'aller pisser
c'est le moment de vous reposer de vous
reposer l'esprit de vous reposer le
cerveau parce qu'on va attaquer
désormais les paieries sow dactyle donc
voilà mettez la vidéo en pause les
persos dactyle c'est pas un aussi gros
morceau que les a reçus au tactile vous
en que les a reçus au tactile pardon ne
vous en faites pas c'est un ça veut pas
dire qu'on va aller survoler on va on va
y aller dans le détail mais comme je
voulais dit déjà la diversité moderne de
paix risque d'acte il n'est pas la
diversité moderne darciaux dactyle donc
il ya beaucoup moins a raconté
du côté des périseaux dactyle donc les
persos dactyle le groupe d rhinau et des
chevaux
c'est parti alors ce qu'il faut savoir
en premier lieu des périseaux d'actes il
est bien c'est qu'il sait comment les
distinguer des arceaux dactyle donc les
arceaux d'actes ils ont un membre par
axones ya les périodes acte ils ont un
membre mais axones hien c'est à dire que
au lieu d'avoir un axe de symétrie entre
les deux doigts du milieu comme les
arceaux dactyle l' axe de symétrie passe
par le doigt du milieu donc les paieries
soda qd ils ont le doigt numéro 3 le
doigt du milieu qui est le doit porter
de charges c'est le doigt principal donc
chez les rhinocéros vous avez un gros
doigt du milieu entouré de petits doigts
sur le deux petits doigts sur les
comptes et le doigt 2 et le doigt quatre
essais le doigt du milieu qui est le
plus important et vous avez la kz2
symétrie qui passe par le milieu chez
les chevaux vous n'avez qu'un seul doit
donc
ça rend les choses beaucoup plus simples
et chez les tapirs alors sur la patte
arrière
vous avez une conditions similaires aux
rhinocéros par contre sur la pâte avant
vous avez quatre doigts mais vous pouvez
voir que le doigt numéro 3 reste le
droit le plus massif et porteurs de
charge
donc même s'il n'ya pas axe de symétrie
mehak sonia il ya quand même doit numéro
trois porteurs de charge chez le tapis
donc c'est ça le truc des périseaux
d'actes il est là où chez les a reçus au
tactile on avait une variété
morphologiques au niveau des dents le
type dominant étant le type celeno
d'hondt chez les personnes actives tous
les espèces son lot faut donc chez les
chevaux lalo fonde aussi est moins
évidente à voir chez les espèces
modernes que chez les espèces fossiles
mais toutes les danses ont dérivé d'un
type low faut donc chez absolument
toutes les espèces donc ça rend les
choses beaucoup plus simples
donc voila voila un arbre très simplifié
dépérissent au tactile donc vous avez
l'ancêtre commun des périseaux dactyle
qui ressemble d'ailleurs pas mal à dire
codexis le dire c'est l'équivalent de 10
à codexis mais avec un membre mais ac
sonia et à partir de ça vous allez avoir
les familles modernes donc tapir chevaux
rhinau et vous avez avoir des familles
et anne comme les bretons terre et les
calicots terre qu'on va détailler un
petit peu donc quel était cet ancêtre
commun des périseaux dactyle bas on sait
pas trop on sait pas trop il ya une
bestiole qui s'appellera dins kia dont
je vais vous parler tout à la fin mais
sinon l'ancêtre commun des périseaux
dactyle il est probable qu'il
ressemblait à fait la cote us donc
fenaco du son en a déjà parlé c'est un
conte deal artres est dans ce qu'on dit
l'art au lieu d'être apparenté au
maisonny qui dès et aux arceaux dactyle
bas lui serait plus apparenté aux
puristes dactyle notamment parce qu'il a
et bien le doigt du milieu qui est plus
gros que les autres donc un membre 10
mai ac sonia et les faits n'a connu et
trouvait principalement à la fin du
paléocène et au début de l'éocène en
amérique du nord et l'amérique du nord
c'est pas anodin non plus parce que
c'est aussi là que le gros de
l'évolution des périseaux d'actes il va
avoir lieu pendant tout le cénozoïque
donc tout ça porte à croire que fait n'a
connu
c'est probablement l'un des meilleurs
candidats pour pour pour être voilà de
très proche de la racine évolutif des
périseaux dactyle et puis sinon ben
voilà on s'attend à ce que les périodes
acte ils soient ancestraux soit
ressemblant aux arceaux d'accident c'est
trop juste par leur lien de parenté
assez évident au sein des lots razia
teria donc le premier groupe de pays
riches aux actes il est probablement le
plus connu le plus connu ce sont
évidemment les équidés alors les équidés
ont des dents énorme et c'est la leur
mais plus leur caractère le plus
distinctif
donc vous pouvez compter ils ont un deux
trois mots l'air et vous pouvez voir
encore une série de trois prémolaires à
l'avant de ces trois mots l'air qui sont
elles aussi gigantesques sur les dents
supérieures et voilà un deux trois mots
l'air est encore un deux trois
prémolaires sur les dents inférieur et
c'est dans son énorme d'autres autant en
ips dont 6 que en surface occlusale les
dents sont fortement rectangulaire chez
les persos dactyle enfin chez les
équidés pardon pourquoi bien tout
simplement parce que ce sont des
herbivores au même titre que les des
grammy nivore au même titre que les les
ruminants mais eux ont une digestion qui
ne se fait pas au niveau de l'estomac
mais au niveau de l'intestin et du coup
ils ont une digestion qui est beaucoup
moins efficace donc ils ont besoin de
mastiquer beaucoup beaucoup plus et
d'avoir une surface de mastication du
coup beaucoup beaucoup plus grande et un
bon moyen de différencier donc les
persos dactyle des arceaux dactyle fin
des ruminants c'est déjà la taille des
dents dont beaucoup plus massive et ips
dont chez les équidés mais aussi le les
incisives donc les incisives vous voyez
il ya des incisives inférieur mais il ya
aussi des incisives supérieures chez les
équidés est pareil elles sont ipso
d'hondt et avec une très grande surface
occlusale donc tout est fait chez les
équidés pour compenser en fait l'absence
de rumination
et c'est dans elles ont évolué à partir
d'un type lofo d'hondt comme on va le
voir un peu plus loin
évidemment ce qui est le plus important
chez les ch et les équidés c'est le fait
qu'il n'est qu'un seul doigt mais ce
doit enfin l'organisation du membres
indique encore une fois que les membres
des équidés était autrefois à cinq
doigts et qu'ils se sont réduits au fil
de l'évolution donc vous avez
probablement autrefois une main qui
était très proche de celle de fenaco du
ce donc que je vous ai montré ici voilà
et qui au fur et à mesure du temps et
biens s'est réduit le doigt du milieu
devenant le seul et unique doit porter
de charges et les doigts latéraux se
réduisant et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une
organisation qui est très similaire à
une main humaine ou un pied humain mais
avec seulement le doigt du milieu qui
reste et ses deux petits métacarpe ou
métatarse résiduelles selon vous
regardez à la main ou au pied sur le
côté qui sont le reste en fait des
doigts latéraux donc cette tendance il
ya une très très belle tendance dans le
registre fossile à la réduction des
doigts latéraux que vous pouvez voir
résumé ici sur ce tableau alors c'est un
vieux tableau parce que c'est une
tendance évolutive qu'on a remarqué
depuis très longtemps
voilà depuis les tout premiers chevaux
que sont par exemple maori puces et
howie puce irako terium alors des fois
en irak au cérium et et holly puces sont
résumés à la même espèce en façon
synonyme ise mais voilà donc vous avez
chez irako terium et slash et aux iep us
les pattes avant
à quatre doigts comme chez le tapir et à
trois doigts à l'arrière et vous allez
avoir le look une tendance à la
réduction des doigts latéraux fils de
l'oligocène du miocène etc jusqu'à et
cus moderne chez qui les doigts latéraux
sont réduits à de simples mots qu'on
appelle bien souvent les splint bonne
donc voilà ce qu'on voit là ce sont les
spleen bonne donc on les voit encore
chez pas mal de chevaux moderne et
souvent aussi ce qu'on a c'est juste la
fosse en fait despleen bonne des fois
les spins beau
même son absence mais on a la fosse et
bien c'est spleen bones et le reste de
ses doigts latéraux qui ont fini par
disparaître au final donc ça c'est
interprété comme une adaptation à un
milieu plus ouvert donc en milieu ouvert
vous avez une adaptation à la course et
cette adaptation à la course se fait par
la réduction de
des doigts latéraux comparé au milieu
fermé où finalement les doigts latéraux
ne sont pas un problème et cela va aussi
de pair avec l'augmentation de la taille
des chevaux donc là vous avez un exemple
typique de cheval à 3 doit donc y
parions qu'on retrouve absolument
partout dans le monde
donc en afrique en europe et hyperion
vous pouvez voir donc il alla dans la
surface occlusale typique des équidés
très très carré avec une forte ipso dont
6 donc c'est définitivement à cheval il
n'y a pas de doute là dessus donc les
seuls trucs qui le distingue d'un cheval
moderne c'est qu'il est un peu plus
petit qu'il a des doigts en plus à
l'arrière du sabot et il a cette petite
ces petits ornements en dentelle en fait
sur le sur la face occlusale donc ça
c'est un truc qu'on voit pas chez les ch
et les chevaux moderne c'est petit c'est
petit de persil à sion cette paire cilad
ce bouquet d'euros maring non je sais
pas ce je ne sais pas comment décrire ça
voilà c'est un peu des ornementations en
dentelle voilà qu'il n'y a pas chez le
cheval moderne donc l'histoire des
périseaux dactyle enfin des chevaux
c'est vraiment l'histoire
ça suit l'histoire finalement encore une
fois je le disais déjà de l'ouverture de
l'environnement à partir de l'oligocène
donc à partir d'un environnement de
forêt fermé vous avez ouverture de la
savane ouverture de l'environnement avec
de plus en plus de savane et donc une
lignée qui va rester adapté à
l'environnement de forêt mais qui va
finir par disparaître et une autre
lignée et enfin des lignes et qui vont
rester adapté aux environnements
forestier mais qui vont finir par
disparaître et d'autres lignes et qui
vont s'adapter à l'environnement de
savane
une d'entre elles survivre à celle qui
va donner et cus et donc tout ça va avec
l'augmentation de la taille puisque
évidemment quand vous vivez en savane
vous devez courir plus vite parce que
vous pouvez pas vous cacher et pour ça
il faut des longues jambes
ça va aussi avec une augmentation de la
taille parce que la digestion des
matières végétales est beaucoup plus
simple pour un animal de grande taille
simplement parce que vous augmentez
finalement la taille de la chambre de
fermentation de l'intestin et encore une
fois je le rappelle la digestion des la
digestion par l'intestin et très
inefficace comparé à la rumination donc
vous avez besoin d'une très très grosse
chambre de fermentation et les graminées
sont beaucoup moins nourrissante que les
feuilles ou les fruits
évidemment donc donc ça va de pair du
coup avec cet environnement plus ouvert
et l'adaptation à un régime grammy
nivore et vous avez aussi évidemment
l'évolution en plus de la taille plus
grande vous avez l'évolution aussi des
dents des dents qui commence donc lofo
dont alors ça se voit très bien sûr
celle là vous voyez un loft ici et 2e
l'ofs
ici des dents qui commence lofo dont tu
es en fait 7 laux fonde aussi va rester
bien visible chez les espèces qui vont
rester
follivores et frugivores donc ici vous
avez un loft comme ça en forme de s es
un deuxième l'ofs en forme de s
ici et ici vous avez ce qu'on appelle
lektroluv donc c'est le mur externe
muraille externe de la dent et de ce
côté là vous avez ce qu'ils vont devenir
grammy nivore et qui vont donner le
change les chevaux moderne et cus chez
qui la halle aux fourneaux si en fait va
être estompée par lipso dont 6 donc
comme les dents vont devenir ipsos en
fait la surface va être complètement
usés on va plus on va pu arriver à avoir
finalement le halo fonds dont 6 mais ici
vous reconnaissez encore voilà un l'ofs
en forme de s est le deuxième neuf ici
en forme de s donc là on voit encore la
halle aux faux nom si chez plio ipu ce
qu'on voit ici chez hip hop us voilà il
suffit de suivre la morphologie de celle
of hell of vers l'avant de l'offre vers
l'avant alors vers l'avant de l'offre
vers l'avant mais qui chez et cus
moderne finalement est à compass et de
l'offre sont accompagnés de deux cuts
speed supplémentaires qui elle aussi
suze avec lips aux dents si donc vous
avez vous avez fatalement une
morphologie qui est beaucoup plus
complexe et donc évidemment augmentation
de la surface 2
de mastication qui va avec justement
cette type sol on s'y met du coup
augmentation de la hauteur de la
couronne donc les chevaux n'ont pas
commencé avec des couronnes haute ils
ont commencé avec des couronnes basse
voilà et comme vous pouvez le voir donc
il ya une grande diversification des
chevaux durant le milieu scène et le
pliocène mais ils ont fini par se faire
comme je le disais complètement bouffé
par les ars you dactyle c'est pour ça
qu'il ya plus que et cus aujourd'hui et
alors évidemment je vous montre des
diagrammes où on voit la taille des
chevaux augmenté et la longueur des
jambes augmenter et des tendances
évolutives bien nettes mais évidemment
l'histoire est évidemment plus compliqué
que ça ce n'est pas seulement une
histoire d'augmentation de taille c'est
aussi une histoire de diversification
donc là vous avez des chevaux tels que
nani puce qui vivait à l'époque de bas
du miocène et du pliocène et qui était
de petite taille donc la taille des
chevaux n'a pas fait enfin des équidés
n'a pas fait que augmenté elle s'est
diversifiée d'animaux de petite taille
jusqu'à des animaux petits moyens et
grands et il se trouve que par un
curieux caprices du destin il ne reste
plus que les grands ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est tenté de vouloir
tracer une droite qui va d'ici à là
voilà on a envie de tracer une ligne
évolutif qui part des débuts petit des
chevaux jusqu'aux fins grande des
chevaux mais en réalité voilà il ya
toute une diversité de chevaux qui a
existé et ce n'est que par un curieux
caprices du destin que que seules les
grandes espèces ont survécu et c'est bon
et c'est ce qui rend aussi les chevaux
aussi faciles à étudier pour les
étudiants parce que justement il ne
reste plus qu'une
on a commencé avec un genre irako terium
slash et aux puces et on termine avec un
genre et cus donc ça rend le
ça rend l'histoire vachement plus simple
mais la vérité c'est que c'est pas si
simple a donc hélas ou encore une fois
c'est très intéressant c'est de
constater que l'évolution des chevaux
est fortement liée à l'amérique du nord
donc irako terium apparaît en amérique
du nord
enfin et où il put sa part et en
amérique du nord et son cousin irako
terium migrent en europe à l'eocène
ensuite vous avez irako terium qui
disparaît en europe mais les chevaux
continue à évoluer en amérique du nord
en mio et puces notamment qui a
l'oligocène et au miocène va se
disperser pour donner en critérium ici
puis on a eu par ion qui se dispersent
depuis l'amérique du nord à partir de
son ancêtre puis excuses qui évolue
enfin en amérique du nord il ya trois
millions d'années et va se répandre à
travers le monde pour données ipp idiot
en amérique du sud et les chevaux
domestiques les ânes et les zèbres sur
le continent sauf que il y a dix mille
ans de cela pour une
pour des raisons de changement
climatique et d'arrivée des êtres
humains en amérique du nord et bien
léché les équidés disparaisse totalement
d'amérique
alors ça j'aimerais bien passer un petit
peu de temps là-dessus
les équidés qui disparaissent d'amérique
après avoir passé tout le cndd aux ics a
évolué là sachant que l'amérique du nord
a toujours été le centre de
diversification principal des équidés
c'est un peu comme si les primates
disparaissait d'afrique humains inclus
donc vous imaginez vous connaissez
l'évolution humaine vous savez à quel
point elle est liée à l'afrique
vous imaginez que d'un seul coup en
quelques milliers d'années y ait plus un
seul humains qui vivent en afrique c'est
un peu ça qui s'est passé avec les
équidés d'un seul coup y'a plus à seul
équidés qui a vécu en amérique du nord
et les équidés que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui en amérique du nord les
chevaux en fait les mustangs qui sont
les chevaux sauvages d'amérique du nord
moderne
ce sont les descendants des chevaux qui
ont été ramenés par les conquistadors
est un peu plus tard parler parler les
européens quoi c'est pas du tout des
chevaux natifs d'amérique du nord
donc voilà voir les équidés disparaître
d'amérique c'est un peu comme voir les
primates humains inclus disparaître
d'afrique sais c'est un peu bluffant
c'est fortement s'est fortement perturbé
ça fait partie des grands événements on
va dire du cénozoïque alors on en a fini
avec les équidés si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur les équidés
c'est l'évolution des équidés c'est un
exemple encore une fois textbook il ya
tellement d'articles et de
et de vidéos et de contenus sur
l'évolution des équidés que voilà c'est
pas la peine d'y passer quatre heures
c'est c'est un exemple classique et il
ya des informations absolument partout
donc maintenant on passe au tapis rider
donc les tapirs deux grandes familles
actu enfin il ya deux grands genres de
tapir actuelle le tapir d'asie que vous
voyez ici et qui est noir et blanc et le
tapir d'amérique du sud qui est brun
voilà ça c'est la diversité des tapirs
moderne merci au revoir
voilà comment on reconnaît un tapir bat
déjà ils ont les ils ont beaucoup plus
de droits que les autres comme je les
dis ils ont le type primitif avec 4
doigts à l'avant et trois doigts à
l'arrière le doigt du le doigt numéro 3
est temps que très faiblement plus grand
que les autres contrairement à ce qu'on
voit chez les rhino et les les équidés
donc ça c'est le type primitif et ils
ont conservé une dentition qui est alors
certes très fortement l'eau faut donc
mais aussi bracchi dont tu donc c'est
vraiment le type primitif dedans bras kg
faut donc qu'on retrouve chez les tapirs
donc ça c'est et ça c'est tout
simplement parce que les tapirs en fait
sont des sondés follivores ils sont
primitivement follivores et vivent dans
la forêt donc ils ont conservé le type
écologique qui était le type ancestrale
chez les personnes at il donc ya pas de
raison que leur morphologie change
change tant que ça bon leur morphologie
dentaire et leur façon de se déplacer
parce qu'à côté de ça ils ont évolué à
un truc qui est très très dérivés me
faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit les
tapirs ne sont pas des fossiles vivants
ils ont ils ont évolué et ils ont
notamment ceux la trompe
la fameuse trompe des tapirs qui laisse
son empreinte très fortement sur le
crâne puisque au lieu d'avoir les
naseaux au bout du nez et ben les
naseaux sont là voilà donc les
c'est un peu comme un évent finalement
sauf que au lieu de lieu d'être ouvert
directement vers le haut bas s'est
ouvert vers l'avant sur une trompe donc
vous avez les muscles de la trompe qui
sont très puissants et qu'ils s'insèrent
dans cette fausse que vous voyez sur le
côté ainsi que sur le museau ici vous
avez d'autres muscles ici donc c'est
finalement le muscle des lèvres
supérieures c'est la lèvre supérieure
qui fusionne avec le nez pour former la
trompe
c'est aussi ça qui se passe chez les
éléphants et ici vous avez l'os nasal du
cou qui est juste au dessus finalement
delà de l'ouverture des naseaux donc
donc les tapirs ne sont pas évidemment
des fossiles vivants et on quand on
regarde leur registre fossile on se rend
compte que l'évolution de la trompette
un phénomène relativement récent
puisqu'il n'apparaît que vers
l'oligocène ya que vers l'oligocène
qu'on commence à avoir une rétraction
des naseaux très faible d'abord puis
très prononcé du niveau du même niveau
que chez les tapirs moderne ogmyos n
mais on a une origine très lointaines
des tapirs pendant lesquelles voilà il y
avait pas d' alors il ya eu des exemples
de compte d'évolutions convergentes de
trompe d'ailleurs à celle étape ya donc
notamment chez les locaux dont ty et
donc la lignée des tapirs c'est une
évolution extrêmement complexe à
l'eocène qui finalement aujourd'hui
encore une fois ne se résume qu'à quotas
pire sud américain est au tapis rires
asiatiques
et enfin last but not least les
rhinocéros idées ou devrais je dire les
rhinocéros aux ide parce qu'il ya
plusieurs familles à l'intérieur des
rhinocéros et des mails
à l'intérieur des rhinos et auto id mais
la seule famille qui subsistent
aujourd'hui ce sont les rhinocéros idée
alors comment on reconnaît un rhinocéros
idées et ben on le reconnaît à ses dans
ses dents sont fortement le feu dont tu
mais elles sont aussi fortement ipso
d'onde
donc vous avez des dents massive
absolument gigantesque encore plus
grosse que celle des équidés mais
contrairement aux équidés lalo fondons
ci est toujours reconnaissable malgré
lips dont 6 malgré le fait qu'ils aient
une usure très forte
donc vous avez cette très haute muraille
et cette très forte nos fans aussi et
comme chez les équidés vu qu'ils ne sont
pas ruminants et bien ils ont des
prémolaires qui sont fortement mot la
risée donc voilà là vous avez un deux
trois mots l'air et de prémolaires
fortement mot la risée qui vont assister
les molaires finalement dans la
mastication de la nourriture pour
compenser le fait qu'ils ne sont pas
ruminer et chez les rhinos érotiser le
crâne et concave sur le dessus parce que
vous avez justement la corde alors la
corne chez les rhinocéros idée
contrairement à celle des ruminants
n'est pas une corne osseuse c'est une
corne de kératine pur donc ici vous avez
juste un manchon dos rugueuse qui sert
d'insertion à la corne mais sinon la
corne elle même n'est que kératine
finalement c'est comme du cheveux
tressés quoi si vous voulez c'est une
sorte de gros cheveux tressés rigide la
cornes des rhinocéros idées et alors les
rhinocéros idées en jaune ici font
partie d'un groupe plus grand qui
s'appelle les rhinos et auto id laisser
rinôçérôse aux idées bien il avait une
diversité
assez assez grande pendant les eaux
saines et le lit gaussen donc il ya des
exemples que de rinôçérôse aux ide que
vous connaissez très certainement comme
les amis nos dotted et donc les âmes
innocentes idée ce sont les hip hop au
rhino si vous préférez donc décédé rhino
pottas mus parce que bah déjà ils ont
des défenses comme les hippos les
canines sont transformés en défense et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on trouve chez
aucun autre
groupe de rinôçérôse aux ide et ils ont
des doigts ils ont les jambes qui sont
très courtes avec des doigts très
fortement écartés ce que vous pouvez
voir ici comme les hippopotames parce
qu'il était semi aquatique et vous avez
aussi le la narine qui est un peu
rétracté
donc ce qui indique aussi possiblement
la présence d'une d'une lèvre supérieure
presque en forme de trompe pas c'est ce
que vous voyez là sur cette
reconstruction la lèvre supérieure et
très mobile et forment presque une
trompe et surtout les rhinos héros tohid
n'avait pas de cornes comme vous pouvez
le voir sur ce crâne
les rires les amis nos dons ty pardon
n'avait pas de cornes donc donc les les
amis nos dons titre c'est le premier
exemple de rinôçérôse aux ide donc qui
est apparu à l'eocène mais qui a fini
par s'éteindre à l'oligocène ensuite
vous avez les irako d'autres idées alors
avant que vous vous inquiétez vous
connaissez tous probablement un irak au
don inné puisqu'il a encore une fois il
est il a été une des stars de sur la
terre des géants et c'est le parent à
ceyrat terium ou un dricot terium ou
ballouchy terium ces trois noms
désignent la même la même bestioles le
para serra terium étant le non valide
donc un dricot terium n'est plus le non
valides de parra serra terium du moins
jusqu'à la prochaine fois qu'ils
changeront d'avis et et donc les lazy
racodo ty et le para serra terium
appartient aux ir accordons idées et il
descend en fait de ce qu'on appelle les
rhinocéros coureurs parce que c'est des
rhinocéros qui ont de très longues mais
t'as pod
vous pouvez voir ici les très longues
étapes mode de para serra therion donc
les méta pod ce sont les métatarse et
les métacarpe
donc c'est la partie distale finalement
de des jambes qui sont une adaptation à
la course donc c'est ce que vous pouvez
voir ici les irako d'anti des qui
ressemble finalement à des chevaux au
final et qui remplaçait les chevaux à
l'époque où il n'y avait pas encore de
chevaux
et donc chez les y raconte idée ce que
vous avez aussi des défenses mais ce
sont les incisif qui forment les
défenses comme chez pas comme chez part
à ceyrat terium par exemple vous voyez
ici le crâne de parra serra terium donc
vous avez des défenses mais ce sont les
incisives et non pas les canines qui
forment les défenses et encore une fois
vous avez des espèces qui n'ont pas de
cornes et chez par at-c à l'intérieur
vous avez une rétraction du nez qui
indique encore une fois la présence
d'une lèvre très probablement fortement
mobile donc part à ceyrat terium est
connu pour être l'un des plus
probablement le plus grand mammifère
terrestre qui ait jamais vécu
certainement deux fois la taille d'un
éléphant moderne
ce titre est concurrencé par certains
certains mastodontes et certains alors
certains proboscidiens de manière
générale bon après c'est comme on l'a
dit sur notre épisode sur le
brachiosaure voilà les estimations de
poids du corps ça ça va et ça vient quoi
donc par acer à terium était
probablement l'un des plus grands voilà
c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire évidemment
même à l'intérieur même de parra serra
terium il y avait des variations de
taille
donc voilà c'est petit diagramme là au
fait je vous ai pas dit mais c'est petit
diagramme montre la dentition primitive
et la dentition dérivés donc là vous
avez les petites incisive petit canine
et là vous avez très petit incisive et
très grosse canine chez les amis nos
dotted là vous avez les petites incisive
et petit canine c'est le trip primitive
et là vous n'avez plus de canines et des
incisives en forme de défense chez les
ch et les irak au ton idée mais voilà
toute cette belle diversité de
rhinocéros de rinôçérôse aux ide
primitive à la fin de l'oligocène ils
sont quick encore une fois très
certainement dû à ce grand changement
climatique qui a eu lieu
et au fait que les ars yoda qd ils vont
prendre le pas par delà les qui vont
prendre le pas sur les périodes actes il
vous avez aussi le fait que tout
simplement bien les rhinocéros ty et les
vrais rhinocéros donc vont aussi
concurrencer les autres rinôçérôse aux
ide
parce que là il va y avoir aussi une
diversité formidable
de rhinocéros comme je vais vous le
montrer juste après donc comment est-ce
qu'on distingue ces rhinocéros ces
rhinocéros idée donc les vrais
rhinocéros des autres rinôçérôse aux
idées bien encore une fois c'est sur les
défenses donc les rhinocéros idéaux -
primitivement parce que les rhinos
beaucoup de rhinocéros modernes vont
complètement perdre leur incisive et
leurs canines
mais les rhinocéros les rhinos érotisée
au moins primitivement au des défenses
et alors il s'agit des incisives qui les
incisives du dessus formant une espèce
de pelles et les incisives du dessous et
en pro clive donc c'est le cheadle tusk
complexe des des rhinocéros idée donc en
forme de pelle sur le dessus et proclif
c'est-à-dire incliné vers l'avant en bas
donc encore une fois le type primitive
ici et le type dérivés ici donc vous
allez avoir une tendance à la perte de
la canine donc par exemple chez le
rhinocéros d'inde
vous avez ici il ya plus de canines en
fait il reste plus que les incisives et
vous avez par celle rhinocéros blancs
donc le rhinocéros typique africa et
bien vous n'avez plus d'incisives ni de
canine du tout donc après il va y avoir
une tendance à la perte des incisives et
des canines qui va être qui va aller de
pair avec le développement de la taille
de la corne et c'est là où je disais
vous voyez c'est une tendance évolutive
qui se retrouve aussi chez les
rhinocéros donc le la compensation par
l'ornementation crânienne de la perte
des dents ou plus ou inversement
c'est le changement en fait d'un mode de
combat avec les dents vers un mode de
combat
avec les ornements crânien qui est moins
dangereux au final parce que vous voyez
ses incisives là elles sont quand même
vachement pointu si vous vous mettez à
vous battre avec ça vous risquez de
sérieux de sérieux dégâts
donc voila et là où c'est intéressant
c'est qu'on associe beaucoup les
rhinocéros à la faune africaine je veux
dire c'est évidemment un événement un
élément emblématique de la faune
africaine et ben les rhinocéros il
n'arrive pas en afrique avant le mi
hossein
donc voilà toute cette histoire que je
vous ai montré c'est une histoire qui
est nord américaines européennes et
asiatiques et lé pa africaine avant le
début du miocène et c'est pareil aussi
pour les chevaux d'ailleurs vous et
montrez la petite carte tout à l'heure à
nîmes et qui montrait les événements de
dispersion des chevaux la dispersion des
chevaux les zèbres les zèbres n'arrive
pas en afrique avant le pléistocène voix
y avait des ja vaidéhi parions avant en
afrique mais les zèbres qui sont si
typique de l'afrique il arrive qu au
pléistocène et pas avant ça donc voilà
c'est ça qui est marrant aussi avec ce
court c'est que ça permet de voir les
origines de la faune africaine qui sont
presque jamais africaine on verra avec
les pennons gueulé qui appartiennent aux
afro terre qui a une partie de la foi
d'africaines qui est endémique d'afrique
mais c'est une toute petite partie de la
faune africaine moderne en réalité mais
on développera sa
durant le prochain cours avec les
pédoncules est donc maintenant avant de
terminer un petit tour de la diversité
des rhinos érotisée alors les rhinocéros
les rhinocéros on a évidemment tendance
à les associer à leurs cornes mais c'est
pas vrai il n'y a pas toujours eu des
cornes chez les rhinocéros idée voyez
par exemple télé osséja ce qui
d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir à la
petitesse de ses membres et à
l'écartement de ses doigts que c'était
aussi un hip hop hausse et ross comme
les amidons et idées mais telle est au
serrage vous pouvez voir il a des
incisives proclif donc c'est
définitivement un rhinocéros idées et
pas un ami d'auto un ami naudon idée
mais par contre il n'a pas de cordes
voyez il n'y a pas de surface rugueuse
sur le sommet du crâne
à côté de ça vous avez pleuré c'est ross
donc qui nous vient de gannat donc
l'euro c'est ross qui vient de gannat en
france lui il a deux zones rugueuses
pour les cornes une de chaque côté des
naseaux donc en gros vous aviez deux
cordes pointant l'une à côté et lui
l'autre de l'autre côté
vous avez dit à ceyrat terium qui est
l'équivalent de pleurer ces races qui
est l'équivalent de télé osséja semer en
europe donc encore une fois c'est une
espèce qui vient de france 10 à ceyrat
terium qui veut dire deux fois pas de
cornes puisque encore une fois il est le
sommet du crâne qui est complètement
lisse et encore une fois vous voyez le
vous voyez bien les incisives proclif
ici et ses incisives proxival se
retrouve encore chez certaines espèces
de rhinocéros moderne et notamment les
rhinocéros asiatiques
donc le rhinocéros indien et le
rhinocéros de sumatra que vous voyez
enfin le rhinocéros indien que vous
voyez ici le rhinocéros de sumatra que
vous voyez là
donc vous voyez bien les incisives
proclif et alors là où c'est intéressant
c'est de regarder chez le rhinocéros de
sumatra
ce petit élément ici qu'on trouve à
l'intérieur des narines
ce petit élément c'est un septembre
nasale il est partiel chez le rhinocéros
de sumatra mais il est complet chez
plein d' espèce fossile et notamment de
les espèces fossiles qui sont
certainement parmi les plus
emblématiques des fossiles de rhinocéros
que sont le rhinocéros laineux que vous
voyez ici donc le rhinocéros laineux qui
vous voyez la plus décisive donc c'est
pas sur les incisives qu'on arrivera à
se baser pour pour l'identifier mais par
contre il a le cepd homo ce entre les
narines et ça ça pourrait indiquer
possiblement un lien de parenté avec le
rhinocéros de sumatra
donc ça c'est le rhino laineux et ça
c'est le l'asmo terium donc le plus gros
rhino qui ait jamais existé
le plus gros vrai rhinocéros est idées
et qui est connu pour avoir cette corne
absolument gigantesque qui fait que des
fois les gens l'associent à la licorne
bon ok c'est un période active ok il a
une corne sur le front mais enfin de
l'associé ça
une licorne quand même c'est un peu
abusé mais bon passons
mais en tout cas ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est qu'il ya septembre
nasale vous voyez et ce septembre nasale
pareil semble indiquer une parenté avec
le rhinocéros de sumatra ce qui veut
dire qu'en fait encore une fois le sepa
l'afrique le centre site ou 6e septum
nasale est un indice de parenté fiable
avec le rhinocéros de sumatra
eh bien ça veut dire que ça veut dire
qu'encore une fois le centre des
diversités des rhinocéros idée c'est pas
l'afrique c'est l asie une fois de plus
et tout parce que toutes ces espèces ont
des noms des ondées zone de dispersion
qui sont eurasiatique ou lors asiatiques
et et pas africaine en fait donc
l'afrique s'est définitivement pas le
berceau des rhinocéros quoi
contrairement à ce que la faune actuelle
semble croire l'afrique ce n'est qu'un
refuge finalement pour les rhinocéros
moderne ainsi que pour les zèbres
au final donc et l'asmo terium il est il
est aussi intéressant a mentionné parce
que il a des dents qui sont à croissance
continue regardez ses molaires donc la
surface occlusale est très complexe
complètement encore une fois ces
éléments en dentelle ou en persil comme
chez hyperion mais là vous voyez il n'y
a pas deux il n'y a pas de limite à la
racine en fait donc la racine n'est pas
fermée celle à ce matériau donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle une non pas une dent ipso
donc mais ips lots dont tu donc une dent
ips lots dont c'est une dent qui
n'arrête jamais de croître tant que
l'animal est vivant et ça ça indique un
régime extrêmement coriace donc un
animal qui devait certainement se
nourrir des plantes des steppes des
graminées des steppes
ce qui nous amène et finalement qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire à propos des
rhinocéros africains que sont le
rhinocéros blancs et le rhinocéros noir
bat déjà ils sont très similaires là à
l'autre ils ont tous les deux deux
cornes bien développés ils ont tous les
deux
aucune défense donc les défenses sont
complètement perdus chez l'un et chez
l'autre
donc finalement ils sont pas si
différents que ça et ce qui les
différencie bas contrairement à ce que
leur nom indique c'est pas la couleur
parce que les rhinocéros noirs sont pas
noirs et les rhinocéros blancs sont pas
blancs en fait c'est un problème de
traduction et puis du coup que mon
diaporama et en anglais que je n'ai pas
changé en france est basse et ses
pratiques parce que ça va me permettre
de vous expliquer en fait donc les
rhinocéros ni blancs ont une lèvre
supérieure qui est carré alors que les
rhinocéros noirs ont une lèvre
supérieure qui est triangulaire
donc ça c'est parce que les rhinocéros
noirs mangent des feuilles
alors que les rhinocéros blanc c'est des
tondeuses à gazon c'est ils ont un gros
muscles bien large et ça leur permet de
manger des graminées directement au sol
donc et ça ça directement à voir avec
leur nom pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'est
leur nom est une erreur de traduction
depuis l'afrikaans jusqu'à l'anglais les
premiers africains les premiers bourg
les afrikaners quand ils sont arrivés en
afrique du sud
ils ont vu ces rhinocéros avec un mufle
large et il le rappeler le rhinocéros un
buffle large vite
voulant dire large celle et celle en
afrikaans donc vite
w it est veut dire large et se vite a
été récupéré par les anglais est traduit
en white au lieu de wyde donc wide en
anglais veut dire large mais ils se sont
plantés et ils ont traduit ça en white
et du coup par opposition les rhinocéros
qui n'était pas white les rhinocéros
africains qui ne sont pas white et bah
ils sont blacks
et voilà comment on finit avec le
rhinocéros blancs et le rhinocéros noir
là n'étant pas blanc et l'autre n'étant
pas noir voilà mais en réalité ils sont
très très proches l'un de l'autre ce
sont quand même deux genres différents
parce qu'il ya une différence de taille
et de morphologie générale du crâne
prononcer puis comme j'ai dit il ya une
différence de régime alimentaire très
prononcé aussi mais globalement ils
descendent d'un ancêtre commun qui est
un l'afrique
très récemment très probablement à la
fin du miocène voir au pliocène et puis
après vous avez d'autres groupes de
perry sow dactyle qui sont moins connus
et qui dit
mais qui sont quand même qui valent le
coup qu'on s'y arrête rapidement se sont
pas des rhinocéros alors on a tendance à
les appeler derry nos zéros des
rhinocéros abusivement mais ce ne sont
pas des rhinocéros donc par exemple vous
avez les calicots tes rides et les
calicots terry dès qu'ils sont
finalement le résultat de ce qui
arriverait si un gorille violer un
cheval donc voilà vous avez une tête de
cheval avec un corps de gori y voyait
des bras qui sont plus longs que les
jambes et vous avez alors ici les
reconstituer en train de marcher sur les
phalanges bon c'est pas le cas du
squelette et honnêtement je suis pas sûr
de laquelle des deux est la meilleure
des reconstructions en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que les calicots terre
idées sont bien caractérisées par leurs
phalanges vous voyez la phalange
terminal la phalange unguéal est là
cette espèce d'un tentation qui fait
qu'on dirait qu'il ya deux griffes qui
la termine bas ça c'est parce qu'il y
avait des grosses griffes qui s'insérait
là on voit ça aussi si je me trompe pas
chez les paresseux les paresseux ont des
phalanges assez similaires parce qu'il
ya des grosses griffes à la fin donc
c'est pour ça que ici il est reconstruit
en train de marcher sur c'est sûr c'est
sur ces phalanges et pas sur ses doigts
c'est parce que d'après le fait qu'il y
avait des grosses griffes au bout de ses
doigts ce qui est quasiment certain bah
c'est très peu probable qu'ils ne
marchait avec les mains à plat comme ça
parce que ça risquait d' user ses
griffes donc voilà pourquoi vous pouvez
retrouver des fois des reconstructions
de calicots terre en train de marcher
sur leurs phalanges donc voilà un détail
plus de plus près d'une de ses phalanges
très caractéristique mais sinon les
dents sont vraiment similaires à celles
des rhinocéros est très difficile pour
les non spécialistes de différencier
pareil un autre groupe qui ressemble
beaucoup beaucoup aux rhinocéros mais
qui en fait ce serait peut-être plus
apparenté aux chevaux mais bon voilà sur
les
dans les grandes lignes c'est du ce et
du rhinocéros like ça ressemble à du
rhino et ce sont les bronches haute et
reed et donc les bretons terre idées ils
n'ont vécu calais hossein et à
l'oligocène et que en amérique du nord
donc encore une fois sa pointe très
clairement l'amérique du nord comme un
centre de diversification des périseaux
d'actifs importants essais brotteaux
terre idées ils sont surtout connus
parce que vu qu'ils sont noirs
américains ils sont dans tous les livres
de paléontologie évidemment et comme ils
sont nord-américain et de l'éocène et de
l'oligocène bon on en retrouve des tetra
chier dans les badlands et dents et on a
donc des belles séries évolutive avec
une augmentation de la taille une
augmentation de l'ipso dos y ait une
augmentation de lalo faune aussi aussi
donc les dents au final sont très
similaires à celles des rhinocéros
moderne lofo d'hondt et ipso dante
limites
zalando dont tu ici à la halle aux
fourneaux si c'est un peu modifié ici on
voit bien une lofo nancy mais cette
l'eau chaude aussi évolue et devient
limite à l'endos dompter ici c'est
pareil vous voyez que la muraille
externe devient limite en forme de w
je pense même qu'on peut clairement
parler des à l'ombre d'oddo cie dans ce
cas là et donc voilà vu qu'ils sont très
fortement documenté en amérique du nord
et bien les ont fait grand cas de ces
bretons terre dans la plupart des livres
des livres de paléontologie mais bon en
réalité on y trouve que en amérique du
nord on n'y a jamais eu de bron otar
idées en europe ni en afrique et ni en
asie
et voilà bon et puis des américains du
coup il aime bien débattre à propos des
bretons terry des notamment à quoi
servait leur espèce de cochonneries
qu'ils avaient sur le nez encore une
fois il ya une belle tendance évolutive
avec le développement de cette corne au
fur et à mesure des temps géologiques et
de la phylogénie et la grosse question
c'est à quoi ça servait est donc la
dernière hypothèse en date basse et ça
en gros c'est que ça servait de gros
points d'insertion à aux muscles de la
lèvre supérieure à quelle femme me
demanderez-vous je vous répondrai
pourquoi est ce qu'il faudrait que ça
serve à quelque chose
voilà parce que tout n'évolue pas pour
servir à quelque chose
faut arrêter d'être adaptation liste
comme ça c'est pas bien c'est pas bien
tout n'a pas de valeur adaptative non
c'est probablement à caractères sexuels
secondaires encore une fois il se
mettait sur la tronche avec sa très
probablement donc voilà diapo
récapitulative des périseaux dactyle
tout en une slide les périodes actilyse
apparaissent à l'eocène probablement un
ancêtre dans le palais aux scènes qui
devait ressembler à fait une inconnue ce
le tout premier parisseaux dactyle
séradin ce qui a de l'éocène d'asie et
ensuite l'évolution des périseaux
d'actes il va se partager entre l'asie
et l'amérique du nord au fur et à mesure
des échanges phonique entre les deux
continents par le détroit de béring
radine ce kia est déjà fortement le faut
d'autres comme vous pouvez le voir donc
c'est définitivement du pays soda est il
bien bien tapée et puis à partir de là
vous allez avoir tous les différents
types de de péristyle qui vont évoluer
donc les bretons terre et les équidés
donc vous voyez ils sont mis à la base
de l'arbre multiplication parce qu'il ya
des fois où ils sont groupe frère des
fois où ils ne sont pas donc c'est
encore débattu est ce que les bretons
terre sont des chevaux bizarre ou pas en
gros et puis les tapirs idées et les
rhinos et rôti dès qu'ils sont qui sont
proches l'un de l'autre mais qui met
dont le clad comprend aussi les calicots
terre et les abricots terre bon
évidemment les abricots terre sont des
rhinos et auto id donc que vous avez
tous les rhinos et auto id en fait
qu'ils sont par là
donc voilà et tout ça ça a évolué très
très rapidement tout ça c'est la délai
aux scènes donc dès l'eocène moyen vous
avez déjà tous les groupes
les grands groupes de perry sow dactyle
qui sont très très diversifié et dont la
diversité
quasiment faire que baisser et ne durant
le cénozoïque et va notamment prendre
une énorme claque à la fin de
l'oligocène avec la disparition des
bretons terre des calicots terre des
indes rico terre des amis nos dos des
amis nos deux entités de la plupart des
tapirs aux ide donc les lots fillon dont
il est par exemple qui sont très
abondants en europe vont tous
disparaître à la fin de la ligue hossein
donc voilà c'est c'est la débandade à
l'oligocène petit rebond de diversité de
la part des équidés et des rhinos et
rôti des pendants le mignot scène
mais les a reçus au tactile à la fin à
partir du pliocène et du pléistocène les
a reçus et d'actes ils vont complètement
leur botter le cul voilà et c'est ainsi
que s'achève cet épisode se court sur
les arceaux d'activer les personnes
actives j'espère que ça vous a plu et je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
les pennons gueulé c'est à dire les
éléphants les irak aux ide et les
siréniens allez ciao